bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
probablement cette fois-ci j'accueille
mehdi moussaïd de foule au scope le sco
piste au losc j'ai cherché partout les
copies on va dire du max planck
institute à berlin aujourd'hui dit il
salue les épuise otor aussi un serment
d'un livre et d'une nouvelle chaîne
youtube qui s'appelle flos copie et donc
médias est ce que tu peux commencer par
te présenter un petit peu avec proton
ton parcours ouais d'accord bien du
coulage en ce moment je suis à berlin
parce que je travaille à berlin comme tu
l'as dit à l'institut max planck et je
suis chercheur dans un labo de
psychologie en ce moment je travaille
dans un hameau de psychologie il étudie
le comportement collectif des êtres
humains
voilà d'une manière générale donc ça
englobe le déplacement collectif des
piétons dans les rues ou pendant les
grands rassemblements et mais aussi la
propagation des idées et des rumeurs et
des informations sur les réseaux sociaux
par exemple et
une autre dimension qui concerne celle
de l'intelligence collective donc il ya
tout un tas de comportements collectifs
qui émerge quand les gens interagissent
les uns avec les autres en grand nombre
et ce sont ces comportements là qui
m'intéressent et que j'étudie dans mon
quotidien
alors tu me parlais de mon parcours qui
me demande aussi comment je suis arrivé
là ouais donc un parcours un peu bizarre
au début j'étais pas du tout partie pour
être chercheur j'ai suivi une formation
d'ingénieur donc
donc j'ai fait un bac s et puis j'étais
assez à l'aise en sciences tout ça donc
j'ai continué j'étais d'abord à nantes à
la fac à fac de sciences j'ai fait un
bug informatique
et puis ensuite y avait un parc où il y
avait un petit petite ville turque à
sion pour aller en école d'ingénieur et
puis je suis allé au bout sans trop
savoir ce que je voulais faire dans ma
vie en fait je me suis juste dit bon on
est au début des années 2000 je me suis
dit oh à l'informatique ça marche bien
donc je veux faire de l'informatique en
école d'ingé quoi et une fois que j'ai
été diplômé j'ai commencé à prendre un
peu de recul puis je me suis dit bon en
fait non ça me plaît pas trop d'être
ingénieur quoi ce que j'ai vraiment
envie de faire moi c'était de la science
quoi j'avais envie d'être chercheur et
donc j'ai
j'ai tourné un peu pendant pendant un an
en cherchant une opportunité d'intégrer
un labo de recherche un doctorat et puis
j'en ai trouvé un à toulouse à
l'université paul sabatier qui proposait
une thèse de doctorat sur le thème du
comportement collectif des piétons donc
c'est la première fois de ma vie que je
me suis dit qu'on pouvait étudier sa
nouvelle chérie j'ai trouvé ça plutôt
bizarre mais en même temps voilà j'avais
envie de m'engager dans la recherche
donc je me suis dit allez on va faire ça
j'ai candidaté et puis comme j'avais des
bonnes bases en programmation pour faire
des simulations numériques des choses
comme ça par exemple j'ai été pris et
puis j'ai fait cette thèse et puis j'ai
rapidement je me suis passionné pour le
pour le sujet donc là j'étais dans un
labo de biologie j'étais avec des
biologistes qui a étudié comportement
collectif aussi mais dans les groupes
d'animaux sociaux il y avait des gens
qui étudient les bancs de poissons les
colonies de fourmis les nuées d'oiseaux
des choses comme ça et j'étais le seul
qui étudiait les humains mais en fait
tous ces systèmes appartiennent à la
même famille donc donc c'est cohérent
tout ça
la famille des systèmes complexes auto
organisé voilà pour te dire le terme
technique et et ensuite après mon
doctorat qui s'est finie en 2010 je suis
allé dans un labo de physique à zurich
en suisse
et donc là je j'ai intégré un groupe de
physiciens qui étudie aussi les
comportements collectifs des humains des
déplacements collectifs mais avec une
perspective complètement différente avec
une perspective de physiciens donc eux
ils étudiaient par exemple le
l'écoulement des grains de sable ou la
mécanique des fluides ou ce genre de
choses et effectivement on va en parler
sûrement en détails après c'est tout à
fait cohérent de mettre ça ensemble avec
le comportement collectif des mouvements
de foule par exemple parce que il ya
déjà beaucoup de choses en commun et on
peut apprendre beaucoup de choses de la
physique et
et quand j'ai fini cette période je me
suis dit que c'était sympa de passer
d'une discipline à l'autre comme ça et
il y avait une poste qui était
disponible à berlin là où je suis
aujourd'hui dans un labo de psychologie
et donc je suis candidate et je me suis
dit quitte à quitte à être
interdisciplinaire et polyvalent à les
banques ou qu'on va partir en
psychologie maintenant et et est donc
j'ai été pris et à nouveau je suis
encore un peu le seul à y faire ce que
je fais là maintenant je suis entouré de
gens qui étudient le comportement humain
d'une manière générale et un peu les
interactions sociales entre les gens
mais jamais à l'échelle collective et
moi je suis le spécialiste de l'échelle
collective
donc quand j'ai des collègues qui étudie
un aspect psychologique de notre
personne les interactions sociales et
puis soudain ils se rendent compte que
ça s'applique pas juste à une ou deux
personnes mais qu'on peut en avoir un
groupe ou un grand groupe ou une foule
mais ils viennent me voir et puis là on
va essayer de 2,2 globalisé un petit peu
ces comportements individuels à
l'échelle de la foule quoi et donc si je
fais ça depuis que je suis à berlin
maintenant depuis sept ans et puis et
puis voilà voilà je suis ok c'est
chouette et du coup la prochaine étape
c'est quoi ces l'astrophysique
c'est en réalité
en réalité c'est assez confortable parce
que maintenant que j'ai beaucoup de
recul et un peu d'expérience sur mon
sujet je me rends compte que c'est
vraiment interdisciplinaire quoi le
terme comportements collectifs chez les
humains tu peut l'appliquer à plein de
disciplines différentes et si un jour je
dois aller chercher un nouveau un
nouveau boulot dans un nouveau labo
j'aurais pas peur de candidater chez des
économistes par exemple étudier le
comportement collectif des consommateurs
j'aurais pas peur d'aller voir des
infographistes ya une grande communauté
d'infographiste qui essaient de se
représenter de de modéliser des foules
virtuel pour faire des animations dans
les films ou dans les jeux vidéo et qui
font aussi des expériences et des
chercheurs
donc j'aurai pas peur d'aller chez eux
non plus je pourrais aller voir du côté
des sociologues ou dans plein de 6 pin
différentes en fait c'est vraiment c'est
suffisamment vaste pour pour pour
pouvoir passer d'une discipline à
l'autre de manière cohérente quoi c'est
super que c'est marrant et du coup grand
aîné tu as que tu as notamment qu'il
était parti plus pour être ingénieur
puis tout à coup tu étais dit la science
eu un déclic est ce que ça fait
progressivement
ouais un déclic disons que souvent
c'était mon cas et je pense que c'est le
cas de pas mal de monde quand tu sais
pas trop ce que tu veux faire c'est à 10
à 16 ans au lycée 18 ans au bac ou 20
ans à la fac tu suis un peu les rails
quoi et en particulier dans le système
français les rails sont ils sont bien
ils sont bien tracé quoi tu vois c'est
assez facile de rester dedans et de
continuer en allemagne par exemple le
système est un peu différent on va
encourager justement après ton bac à
aller prendre une année sabbatique ou
deux années sabbatiques à faire des
trucs que tu as pas du tout fait dans ta
vie juste pour goûter un petit peu à
différents métiers
mais en france c'est mais en france on
est on est bien mis sur les rails dès le
début et du cou et du cou en fait moi je
me suis jamais vraiment posé la question
de ce que je voulais faire dans la vie
et comme il y avait j'avais j'étais
assez à l'aise en sciences tu vois tu
arrives tu vas en bas qu'est ce tu sors
du bac s
tu vas bon à la fac par exemple le
l'informatique c'est un truc un peu
prometteur donc tu arrives en dogme à la
fac en informatique
l'école d'ingénieurs c'est un petit peu
plus prestigieux donc quand tu vois le
chemin qui va et puis tu vas jusqu'au
bout quoi en fait mais est un moment
donné j'ai été diplômé ingénieur et là
je suis vraiment arriver au bout et
eilat a vraiment tu peux tu es obligé de
sortir des rails quoi tu as une décision
à prendre
je dis bon alors dans quelle entreprise
je vais travailler puis tu regardes un
peu tu ça me faisait pas rêver quoi tu
commences tu es un tube tu fais de la
programmation
c'est pas hyper créatif enfin je
trouvais pas ça je repasse à super
créatif je trouve ça super fun en fait
un chat et un peu le fun et puis et
c'est la première fois donc je devais
avoir je pars à 22 23 ans que je me suis
vraiment posé la question qu'est ce que
je veux faire dans la vie alors qu'avant
je ne l'imposé pas avant je suivais
juste les rails et et et quand je me
suis posé cette question ben je sais pas
j'ai repensé à ce que j'aimais dans la
vie tu sais quand tu es enfant
moi j'aimais bien dans les bandes
dessinées pour enfant j'aimais bien
toujours le pays est toujours un
inventeur un peu fou là un génie sinon
genre léonard le génie ou gérant tous
les mecs il ya un gant de boxe est
accroché sur un ressort la tcp louvre et
puis je tends ring puis là ils inventent
des trucs comme ça et puis j'aimais bien
ce que ses côtés ce savant fou quoi suis
je vais passer pas exactement comme ça
la réalité mais mais mais ce cas un
petit peu c'est un peu ce qui m'attirait
quoi t'as pas cacher les gants de boxe
et chez toi je peux pas j'ai pas fais
d'invention complètement absurde non
plus mais mais c'était un petit peu ce
qui m'attirait début du coup du coup
c'est pour ça que je suis allé voir la
science et la découverte de la foule
balle et elle est de l'étude du
comportement des foules c'est arrivé
après c'était d'abord une passion pour
les sciences
ouais c'était quoi ton sujet de thèse
études expérimentales et modélisation
des déplacements collectifs de piétons
donc études expérimentales parce que on
fait des des expériences donc pour
étudier comment se déplacent les piétons
dans la rue comment ils interagissent et
modélisation parce qu'il ya aussi une
grosse part de modélisation donc on va
essayer de décrire ces comportements et
puis on va les décrire avec des outils
mathématiques ou sur ordinateur et puis
on va implémenter ce modèle dans une
simulation donc avec un programme de
simulation et puis ensuite on fait des
simulations numériques ont essayé de
reproduire ce qu'on a observé puis on
essaie de faire des prédictions et
ensuite on refait des expériences pour
vérifier que nos prédictions étaient
bonnes et puis on fait comme ça dont on
va des allers retours entre les
expériences et les les simulations
coutume chez lui mais d'autres les tons
du coup à la partie la partie
expérimentale elle avait deux aspects ça
pouvait être vraiment des expériences en
laboratoire
eh bien ça pouvait être des observations
en milieu naturel alors milieu naturel
c'est un peu bizarre de dire milieu
naturel parce que c'est ce genre
existent à sion d'une station de métro
un supermarché punk ça fait pas très
naturel comme l'idéal mais c'est
l'expression d'expression scientifiques
et leurs milliers le milieu naturel des
piétons c'est la station de métro si tu
veux et donc les observateurs en milieu
naturel sont faciles à faire quand il
prend une caméra et un trépied et puis
tu vas chercher un endroit intéressant
dans la ville si possible un endroit où
il ya beaucoup de monde et tu cherches
un spot donc un endroit surélevé pour
essayer de filmer la foule par au dessus
et tu places la caméra là et tu es tu
filmes pendant trois heures une demi
journée une journée entière tueur
retourne au labo et tu analystes et
vidéos ce qui est intéressant c'est
justement ce que j'ai beaucoup aimée au
début c'est cette ce côté improvisation
quoi tu vois tu cherches un moyen de
faire ton truc tu as envie de filmer je
ne sais pas une foule qui rentre et qui
sort dans une station de métro
bon bah c'est facile tu vas attentats
station de métro puis tu t'es improvise
un endroit où tu va poser des caméras
donc comme j'étais à toulouse par
exemple une fois on a trouvé une voulais
filmer la place du capitole donc une
grande place à toulouse bien la trouver
une entrée pour aller sur le toit du
bâtiment du capitole qu'à un bâtiment
plusieurs fois centenaires et puis du
coup on est très content avec mon
collègue qu'on a réussi à se positionner
là sur le toit on a placé notre caméra
et puis on regardait la foule par au
dessus qui ont filmé ou bien une autre
technique assez commune c'est quand tu
veux filmer dans une rue une rue
commerçante par exemple une rue piétonne
tu vas te placer sur un balcon d'un
bâtiment adjacent et pour sa battue mais
à la porte et tu sonnes quoi tu sonnes à
toutes et à toutes les portes et puis tu
dis bonjour cnrs aller dire bonjour
police du bonheur j'aimerais me mettre
sur votre balcon en quoi début les gens
il
ils prennent pour un fou quoi ils sont
méfiants et tout mais bon quand explique
un peu ça va ça bout d'un moment ils
comprennent et puis en général les gens
sont très sympas donc tu te places sur
un balcon tu mets ta caméra et tu
reviens à chercher quelques heures plus
tard les expériences en laboratoire
voilà il ya toute la partie
expérimentale aussi donc là
l'observation milieu naturel et faire un
intérêt c'est que c'est là c'est la
vraie vie quoi c'est vraiment comme ça
que se déplacent les piétons dans la
vraie vie ça aussi un inconvénient c'est
que c'est pas du tout contrôler quoi
donc il peut y avoir plein de trucs peut
y avoir des vélos qui passe il peut y
avoir c'est pas le l'environnement tu ne
contrôles pas du tout dans tu peux avoir
plein de choses qui se produisent
l'expérience en laboratoire elle a un
intérêt c'est le contrôle donc tu peux
vraiment contrôler exactement une
situation exactement celle que tu veux
faire c'est un petit peu moins réaliste
dans le sens où les gens savent qu'ils
font partie d'une expérience donc il ya
toujours des petits pieds dans ce sens
là mais mais ils sont ils sont
acceptables et du cou du coup comment ça
se passe bien en général tu loues un
lieu par exemple un grand gymnase parce
qu'il va y avoir du monde avec un peu de
moyens on construit une structure dans
ce gymnase par exemple une pièce donc on
met quatre murs avec une porte donc jeté
une expérience très simple on veut
tester une évacuation par exemple donc
tu construis une pièce quatre murs avec
une porte
et puis tu recrutes des participants par
petites annonces
tu dis on a besoin de 60 personnes et
les 60 personnes arrive tu les mets dans
la pièce tu leur expliques au top départ
ils vont devoir sortir par la porte par
exemple et tu donne le top départ et ils
sortent et puis tu recommences tu fais
pleins pleins de répétition c'est
toujours un petit peu un petit peu
ennuyeux quoi tu peux varier la largeur
de la porte voix j'invente une
expérience là et puis comme ça tu peux
voir quel est l'effet de la largeur de
la porte sur le temps d'évacuation par
exemple est toujours avec plein de
répétition et puis le lendemain on
refait la même chose avec un autre
groupe de participants et encore avec un
autre comme ça on a d une diversité du
groupe qui fait l'expérience et
et c'est toujours c'est toujours
compliqué d'organiser une expérience
avec des foules quoi parce qu'il ya
toujours beaucoup de monde et personnes
en basse et c'est en général quand on
veut une foule on essaie d'avoir une
cinquantaine en même temps ah ouais
c'est ça j'ai fait une expérience
récemment année ils étaient seulement
une environ 40 ils étaient 38 je pense
j'ai une expérience en tête où on est
monté jusqu'à 80 à peu près ça c'est
quand tu veux une foule mais tu peux
aussi étudier les mécanismes individuel
donc les interactions entre les piétons
et pour ça t'as pas besoin d'une foule
d'âgés besoin de quelques piétons
donc on a fait aussi la toute première
expérience que j'avais fait pendant mon
doctorat
on n'avait que deux piétons voulez
savoir comment il faisait pour s'éviter
quand il arrivait face à face et donc on
avait seulement deux piétons avaient
construit un couloir linéaire tout ce
qui est plus simple
et puis on avait un piéton à chaque
extrémité au top départ il devait
traverser le couloir et donc c'est
éviter et nous on voulait voir comment
il allait faire pour s'éviter
il y avait une question scientifique
précise qu'on se posait et donc pour ce
cas là on a besoin que de deux piétons
en même temps parce qu'on va juste
d'étudier l'interaction est il que c'est
quoi la question la voici ce point exact
donc alors c'était la toute première
expérience que j'ai fait pendant mon
doctorat et puis elle concernait le la
coordination pendant une manoeuvre
d'évitement
alors c'est un problème qui paraît tout
bête à premier abord mais en fait qui
est assez intéressant c'est quand deux
piétons arrive face à face sur un
trottoir un peu étroit et qui doivent
s'éviter ils ont une décision à prendre
ils doivent choisir de passer à droite
ou à gauche pendant l'évitement
on va à priori ça permet vraiment une
question stupide de se demander ce qu'il
choisisse la droite ou la gauche mais en
fait il ya quelque chose d'intéressant
c'est que les deux piétons doivent
choisir un côté et ils doivent choisir
le même côté donc s'ils passent tous les
deux à droite ils vont réussir à
s'éviter s'ils passent tous les deux à
gauche ils vont réussir à s'éviter au
plus tôt s'ils choisissent tous les deux
la droite s'est vite s'ils choisissent
tous les deux la gauche il s'est vite
mais s'ils choisissent un côté différent
ils vont se rentrer dedans
autrement dit doivent se coordonner et
ils doivent se coordonner
sans communiquer parce qu'on on se parle
pas et puis ils doivent prendre la
décision en quelques secondes et ils se
connaissent pas donc a priori pourrait
choisir que au hasard ont choisi droite
ou gauche au hasard mais si on choisit
au hasard et on a une chance sur deux de
se rentrer dedans or les piétons ils se
rendent pas dedans une fois sur deux
dont il ya un mécanisme de coordination
entre deux piétons qui étaient inconnus
et on s'est dit qu'elle est ce mécanisme
nice que iasi pas un petit coup d'oeil à
un petit mouvement des pôles à un petit
pas d'un côté un petit pas de l'autre et
on voulait savoir qu'est ce que c'était
quoi donc on a recruté nos participants
il a fait notre expérience et on a
observé des pleins pleins de deux
binômes de participants qui s'est vite
et encore et encore et on a compris
qu'en fait il y avait aucune
communication explicite entre les
piétons
en fait c'est quelque chose d'autre que
les participants qu'on avait choisi
c'est le côté droit donc là de passer à
droite sans même se regarder dès le
premier pas on voyait qu'ils avaient
choisi le côté droit comme s'il y avait
une sorte de règle implicite qui était
partagé par tous les piétons qui disait
en cas d'évitement dans un endroit un
peu étroit choisissez la droite parce
que il ya de fortes chances pour que
l'autre choisissent aussi la droite et
du coup on va réussir à se coordonner
comme ça s'appelle une convention
sociale ou une norme c'est ce genre de
règles implicites qui est partagé puis
ça va permettre aux piétons de se
coordonner pendant un évitement et ils
économisent par 2.2 chez ling alors je
me demande si c'est si c'est la même
chose je pourrais pas te le dire
on va vérifier hockey est et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que le côté
d'évitement donc cette norme qui est
partagé par parler c'est sûrement le
point de shillings parce que ça fait
référence
excuse moi je suis en train de réfléchir
c'est sûrement le point de shillings
pascal schelin j'imagine que ça fait
référence à thomas sterling qui est un
grand économiste qui était très qui
était un des précurseur en terme de
déplacements collectifs en de
comportement collectif donc donc tout ça
ça me paraît très cohérent ce sens de
l'expression point de shillings par
contre je ne connais pas ça se passe et
c'est au ratio est et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que d'un pays à
l'autre le côté d'évitement qu'elle à
cette norme sociale varié donc à
certains pays où tous les piétons sont
d'accord pour s'éviter à droite et puis
y en a d'autres où tous les piétons sont
d'accord pour s'éviter à gauche ce qui
est marrant c'est qu'on dit ils sont
d'accord comme s'il y avait eu une règle
une loi qui était tombée alors qu'en
fait non c'est vraiment un comportement
qui apparaît spontanément à l'échelle
d'une population
c'est quelque chose qu'on arrive a
expliqué assez facilement par un
mécanisme qui est l'apprentissage social
donc en fait
donc en fait l'apprenti l'apprentissage
par renforcement et qui est simplement
un petit un petit programme qui tourne
en veille dans notre cerveau qui dit que
si tu tentes un truc et que ça marche
pas mais le prochain coup tu vas avoir
plus tendance à tenter un autre truc
et si tu tentes quelque chose qui marche
bien le prochain coup tu aura tendance à
le reproduire et donc le truc en
question si c'est la droite ou la gauche
eh bien tu mets plein de piétons
ensemble s'il n'arrive pas assez vite et
ils vont changer de côté et puis la
prochaine rencontre ils vont peut-être
réussir et puis ils vont garder le même
côté et puis quand tu répètes c'est
petit apprentissage à l'échelle d'une
population tu vas te rendre compte qu'il
ya quelque chose qui émergent
c'est une préférence commune et en
fonction des pays la préférence va être
différente parce que c'est en fait la
droite ou la gauche
c'est complètement équivalent temps que
tout le monde se met d'accord sur un sur
une option et une vie de juillet qui
parle des points de shilling où elle
prend l'exemple du lorsque tu veux
rencontrer quelqu'un que tu proposes un
café et du coup se demander pourquoi un
café juste une convention sociale pour
se rencontrer
c'est pas mon café en tant que tel qui
qui a une valeur et non ce genre de
convention n y en a pleins partout le
fait de se faire la bise ou déjà le fait
de se faire la bise sa charge d'un pays
à l'autre
et puis le fait de se faire un certain
nombre de bises ça va changer d'une
région à l'autre et peut-être même le
fait de commencer sa bise à droite ou à
gauche ça peut même varier d'une région
à une autre
donc y'a plein de choses comme ça que
notre cerveau enregistre sans qu'on s'en
rende compte et puis qui va forger comme
ça les comportements collectifs à
l'échelle d'une population et du coup ça
c'est mance et c'est parfois bizarres
des coûts lévis parce que parfois on n'a
pas la même convention quelle autre
personne et c'est exactement comme si tu
allais voyager c'est un français qui
part en vacances en australie par
exemple eh ben il va avoir beaucoup de
mal à éviter les piétons au début quoi
mais le cerveau étant un organe
superpuissant l'adaptation va être assez
rapide si vous voyagez en australie va
falloir quelques jours ou peut-être
quelques semaines avant de commencer à
éviter les autres piétons par la gauche
parce qu'on australiens on s'évite à
gauche et peut-être que parfois on est
tellement habitué à nos conventions que
on s'en rend même plus compte que c'est
des conventions et et que du coup ça ça
c'est intéressant du coude et seront
donc laissés de leur rôle social aussi
est juste pour terminer sur ce projet
parce que ce qui est intéressant c'est
que là on parle vraiment de l'individu
du piéton qui évite un autre piéton qu
on est à l'échelle de l'individu mais
moi toujours je veux monter à l'échelle
de la foule et la question c'est ok si
les gens c'est vite par la droite
préférentiellement en france quel impact
ça va avoir à l'échelle d'une foule
toute entière c'est vraiment l'objet
foule qui va m'intéresser pas l'objet de
piétons le piéton il sert juste à
comprendre la foule
et bien on a fait des observations au
milieu naturel cette fois ci où tu vas
avoir pas deux piétons qui s'est vite en
marche en face à face mais de flux de
piétons qui se déplace en sens opposé
comme dans une rue commerçante en
particulier on est allé faire nos
observations à bordeaux dans une rue
commerçante qui s'appelle la rue
sainte-catherine qui est un énorme axe
piéton avec des piétons des gens qui se
déplacent dans les deux sens et là parce
qu'on se rend compte c'est que il ya un
comportement collectif qui émergent qui
est qu'on appelle une autoroute de
piétons une autoroute de piétons c'est
quand tu vas avoir tous les gens qui se
déplacent dans un sens qui occupe une
moitié de la rue en l'occurrence la
moitié droite et tous les gens qui se
déplacent en sens opposé qui occupe
l'autre moitié comme si la foule avait
décidé de ceux de partager l'espace
disponible entre les deux flux et ça
c'est juste une conséquence du fait que
les gens c'est vite par la droite parce
que tu es vite à un premier une première
personne à droite
et puis celui qui est devant toi après
tu vas encore l'éviter à droite et
encore à droite une petit à petit tu vas
te retrouver un peu plus à droite delà
de la rue et si tout le monde se
retrouve un peu plus à droite de la rue
20 sacrée cette autoroute de piétons ce
qui est génial c'est que quand
l'autoroute de piétons est en place
l'efficacité du trafic piétonnier
s'améliore parce que ça va beaucoup plus
vite comme sur une autoroute de voiture
donc c'est une forme d'intelligence
collective
la première fois dans mon dans mes
recherches que je me suis posé cette
question d'intelligence collective ne se
dire tiens c'est marrant c'est la foule
fait un truc qui est bien quoi qui est
efficace qui est intelligent est ce que
ça pourrait aller plus loin et puis
aujourd'hui je dix ans plus tard je suis
en plein dans cette thématique et je me
suis fait la réflexion l'autre fois où
j'étais dans le métro et que j'étais
payé y avait ce phénomène de foule
deux des autoroutes a2 et de la foule
mais j'étais à contresens et dumas et
côté et c'est horrible terrasse plus
écoutés du mauvais côté alors il ya un
truc intéressant sur ce sujet à ce sujet
c'est que non seulement tu avances plus
mais en plus ce qui va se passer c'est
que tu va perturber l'organisation est
ce que tu vas avoir tendance à scinder
le flux qui arrive en face tu vas avoir
tendance à se scinder en deux et tu vas
créer une petite perturbation qui va
faire que l'ensemble de l'autoroute va
se propager comme ça de personne en
personne et toute organisation va
s'effondrer pendant pendant un certain
temps
du coup la conséquence c'est que tout le
monde va commencer à marcher moins vite
parce qu'ils vont être moins bien
organisée donc en fait le fait que tu
ailles en sens opposé et ben en fait
cela va avoir un impact sur tout le
monde
toi peut-être que tu vas réussir allez
un petit peu plus vite mais tous les
autres eux ils vont ils vont réduire
leur l'efficacité de leurs déplacements
donc il ya une forme de on est tous on
est tous liés les uns aux autres en fait
si tout le monde occupe bien sa place et
on va tous pouvoir aller vite mais s'il
y en a un qui veut faire quelque chose
un peu solo et bien au contraire ça va
ça va perturber le le bénéfice de tous
les autres et donc peut-être là s'il
fait des simulations sa thèse le
sarkozyste encore la simulation et bien
du coup si on continue sur ce projet là
par exemple on tu vas avoir un tu vas tu
vas tu va simuler le déplacement d'un
individu donc c'est juste à l'écran ça
va juste un point qui avancent par
exemple et puis tu vas lui rajouter une
composante
évitement donc tu vas dire ok s'il
arrive en face d'un autre individu et
bien il va se décaler un petit peu vers
la droite par exemple tu peux dire à
quelle quelle va être la la proportion
de droite gauche nous en l'occurrence on
la connaît puisque on l'a mesuré ses 2
85% donc les gens c'est vite 85 % du
temps à droite quand il arrive dans dans
un évitement
et une fois que tu as fait cette petite
modélisation donc que tu a décrit
comment se comporte un individu battante
en envoie plein tu dis à l'ordinateur
maintenant tu vas me renvoyer 10 par
seconde de chaque côté dans une rue et
là tu vois que des simulations elle
engendre la séparation du trafic
piétonnier donc cette autoroute de
piétons dont je te parlais tout à
l'heure
et puis à côté d'une mesure l'efficacité
tu dis ok à quelle vitesse se déplacent
mais piéton quand l'autoroute est en
place puis enlève le tu enlèves la
préférence à droite tu recommences les
simulations tu mesure l'efficacité du
trafic et tu vois qu'il ya une
différence entre les deux donc la
simulation elle prédit que le le la
préférence à droite va avoir un impact
positif à l'échelle de tout le groupe
ensuite tu peux prendre un seul individu
dans ta simulation tunisia ce juste suis
là je vais lui enlever sa préférence à
droite je lui met une préférence à
gauche
donc tu vois qu'ils galèrent et tout
mais après tu mesure l'efficacité pour
tous les autres et tu vois que juste un
seul individu qui fait pas ce qu'il faut
faire
va avoir un impact sur le sur la river
la vitesse de marche de tous les autres
tu peux faire des simulations comme ça
est-ce qu'à des questions des résultats
qui sont le plus surpris dans sa thèse
pendant ma thèse ouais moi je suis du
genre très enthousiaste donc à chaque
fois que j'ai fait c'est merveilleux
alors je vais répondre à un petit peu à
côté du coup parce qu'en gros tous les
résultats que j'avais en surtout quand
c'est des résultats tu sais quand c'est
à découvrir toujours l'impression que
c'est extraordinaire
alors qu'en fait au beauf quoi et et je
vais te répondre à un petit peu à côté
un des trucs qui m'a le plus surpris
c'est un c'est un autre projet qu'on a
qu'on a réalisé qui concernait le
l'étude des petits groupes de piétons
donc dans la rue souvent on se déplace
quand on se déplace on n'est pas tout
seul on est souvent accompagnée on est
accompagné de quelqu'un d'autre et donc
on forme des petits groupes comme ça et
on a fait une étude sur l'organisation
de ces petits groupes on voulait voir
comment ils marchaient ensemble comment
il était quelle était la configuration
de marché des trucs comme ça et ça pour
moi c'était vraiment un projet pas super
intéressant quoi c'était bon ok ça n'a
pas un impact monstrueux sûr je sais pas
sur le la structuration du trafic sur
l'urbanisme ou des choses comme ça mais
et c'est un peu naïvement tu vois et
j'ai publié ça j'ai fait une publicité
efficace sujet et le moment où j'étais
le plus surpris de ma thèse peut-être
c'est la réception de la communauté
scientifique sur cette petite étude
parce qu'en fait c'était pas une petite
étude
je m'en suis rendu compte après c'était
quelque chose qui a été considérée comme
assez important parce que j'étais en
fait le premier à étudier les
déplacements des petits groupes de
piétons ce que jusqu'à présent dans
toute la littérature scientifique ça
paraît un peu fou mais c'est juste une
personne n'y avait pensé on considérait
toujours une foule comme un ensemble
d'individus isolés et pour la première
fois on disait que en fait cet objet
foule
eh bien il n'est pas constitué
d'individus isolés il est constitué de
petits agrégat de petit amar d'individus
qui sont ces petits groupes qui se
déplace à deux ou à trois et ça ça
change est fondamentalement la façon
dont année dont on allait les
modéliser le système foule est en fait
aujourd'hui c'est ma public mais
application qui a été le plus cité celle
qui a eu le plus de succès et ça c'est
fait partie d'eux s'était probablement
ma plus grande surprise pendant mon
doctorat de voir que à quel point c'est
ce que je considérais comme une petite
découverte avait en fait une implication
plus profonde en termes de modélisation
et en terme de com
la façon dont on appréhende le système
ok donc à 1,4 était passé à zurich où tu
as commencé à faire de la physique mais
ce pourrait ce qu'on fait la physique
des fous de comment ça marche alors
figure toi qu'on a commencé dans
l'histoire de la discipline
on a commencé à faire de la physique des
foules avant de faire du comportement
assez c'est assez étonnant mais mais
c'est comme ça
donc le grosso modo ça commence dans les
années 50 que des chercheurs commencent
à s'intéresser aux déplacements des
foules parce que les villes deviennent
de plus en plus remplie de plus en plus
gronder et puis il ya des des ingénieurs
et des urbanistes qui se disent or il va
falloir qu'on ne compte donc on mesure
un petit peu tout ça qu'on quantifie un
peu ça de plus précisément parce que ç'a
un impact sur la façon dont on trouvera
à construire nos villes alors il
commence à faire des petites mesures à
droite à gauche
il découvre par exemple quelque chose
qui nous paraît aujourd'hui très
intuitif mais qui a été découvert
vraiment dans les années 50 c'est le
fait que plus il ya de monde - on va se
déplacer vite et en fait il existe une
relation entre la densité
le nombre de personnes par mètre carré
et la vitesse de déplacement qui est qui
et qui est très propre qui est très
systématique qui s'appelle le diagramme
fondamentale et donc on voit bien que
plus on augmente la densité d'individus
plus la vitesse de déplacement moyenne
des individus va diminuer et puis cette
courbe elle a une forme très précises et
on la connaît très bien et ça a été
mesurée ça dans les années 50 pour la
première fois donc il ya plein de
mesures qui sont faites comme ça et
c'est des mesures très très empirique
c'est à dire on n'a pas vraiment de
cadres théoriques et un moment donné
quand tu as plein de mesures il faut un
cadre théorique il faut quelqu'un qui
met une théorie autour et qui disent ok
ça marche comme ça et puis comme ça tu
vas pouvoir positionner démesuré mieux
les comprendre et la première fois que
j'ai un cadre théorique a été proposée
c'est un physicien qui l'a fait un
australien qui s'appelle leurs ouailles
anderson et c'était dans les années 70
et lui l'a dit ben moi je pense que
on va une foule dans une rue ça se
déplace comme un liquide dans un tuyau
et puis du coup on va utiliser toutes
les outils qu'on a de la mécanique des
fluides pour décrire notre foule et on
va voir si ça marche et ça marchait pas
mal en fait et donc il y avait il
pouvait par exemple transformer la jouer
sur la viscosité du liquide pour
transformer sa vitesse d'écoulement et
puis ça ça va représenter un petit peu
la vitesse de déplacement des piétons
des choses comme ça et donc là pour la
première fois on a un cadre théorique et
de la mécanique des fluides
donc c'est la première fois que quelque
chose et donc c'est de la pure physique
cependant ça marche pas super bien parce
que ça marche bien mais à seulement à
partir d'une certaine densité
d'individus tu vois j'entends il ya
vraiment vraiment beaucoup de monde tu
peux faire l'analogie avec les liquides
s'il ya moins de monde ça commence à
déconner un peu et la modélisation la
compréhension des foules à densité
intermédiaire ça a été compris seulement
dans les années 90 en 1995 plus
précisément par un physicien encore qui
s'appelle dire qu'elle bing et qui a dit
ok on va changer le truc plutôt que de
dire que la foule est un liquide
on va dire que les piétons sont des
particules et ça ça va nous donner
beaucoup plus de liberté c'est toujours
des analogies et avec ça on va utiliser
pas la mécanique des fluides mais la
mécanique newtonienne pour décrire le
déplacement des piétons et on va voir si
ça fait émerger des comportements
collectifs et ça marchait super bien et
donc son modèle ce modèle de piétons
particules qui est sorti en 95 c'est
aujourd'hui celui qui est le plus
utilisé de loin dans toute la
littérature scientifique qui a utilisé
dans les logiciels de simulation
commerciaux et tout ça et c'est pour ça
qu'on est en fait l'aspect
comportemental dans la foule d'un et
finalement il est arrivé il est arrivé
beaucoup plus tard il est arrivé plus
plus au début des années 2000 et
aujourd'hui encore les si tu prends
toutes les disciplines qui étudie le
déplacement des foules
tu vas voir que en majorité ce sont des
ce sont des physiciens et donc moi à ce
moment là je suis allé voir
dire qu'elle bing donc c'est la personne
qui avait créé ce modèle des piétons
particules et c'est dans son laboratoire
que j'ai continué mon ma progression
les piétons particules s'effacer
vraiment chaque chaque piéton et a su su
les lois de newton du coup il se cogne
et puis cyclone il peut revenir en
arrière
voilà exactement donc en gros tu prends
tu prends ton piétons et puis enfin ça
c'est un point à l'écran tu vois pas ce
que c'est très conceptuel et tu dis ok
ils ont dit qu'ils se déplacent comme
une particule on va lui donner des
forces
il a des force de répulsion donc par
exemple quand il s'approche d'une autre
particule ou d'un autre piéton il ya une
force qui va le pousser dans la
direction opposée et on va lui-même pour
une petite différence avec la mécanique
newtonienne c'est qu'on va leur mettre
des forces internes
donc il ya chaque particule chaque
individu a une force interne qui va le
pousser dans une certaine direction est
en fait c'est la direction malgré tu
veux aller quoi si tu veux aller à la
boulangerie toi et bien dans le modèle
tu vas être une particule avec une force
donc une petite flèche là qui te pousse
vers la boulangerie et si tu croises
quelqu'un qui a va y avoir une autre
force qui se rajoutent par dessus qui va
te pousser en direction opposée de ce
quelqu'un est donc tu combine ces
différentes forces et puis ça va te
donner une trajectoire qui va vers la
boulangerie tout en évitant l'autre
personne est comme ça tu peux rajouter
tu peux rajouter des couches de force
comme ça en veux tu en voilà quoi tu
peux dire ok si les piétons qui se
déplacent en groupes l'aller les copains
qui marchent ensemble on va leur mettre
une force d'attraction
on va dire qu'ils sont attirés les uns
avec les autres et bref tu peux tu peut
cumuler plein de force comme ça et donc
tu les cumuls les unes sur les autres
qu'ils rajoutent et puis ça te produis
un déplacement tu mets plein de
particules ensemble et ça te fait un
mouvement collectif un mouvement de
foule et kiko qui ressemble beaucoup à
ce qui est observé dans la vraie vie
alors j'imagine que sais tu que 7
seulement impossible à résoudre
analytiquement du coup ces sanctions des
simulations et des simulations qui sait
des cdc des études c'était des analyses
numériques principalement des
simulations presque exclusivement alors
il ya des mathématiciens qui parce
qu'ils passent à l'analyse macroscopique
donc ils vont commencer à étudier plus
avec des équations et donc pas en
simulation numérique qui arrive à des
riches d'un peu différent mais c'est
tout ça c'est cohérent quoi ça marche
après marche pareil lorsque j'imagine
avec la mécanique des fluides on peut
avoir des équations enfin avec la laine
et oui avec les fluides encore
d'équations mais là avec un truc
particulier exactement alors en fait
c'est son ce sont deux approches que tu
peux avoir sur un sur un comportement
collectif
tu peux commencer à le décrire en
coupant en décrivant le comportement des
individus
donc c'est ce que fait dire qu'elle bing
avec ces particules et ensuite mais
plein d'individus ensemble et ça te
faire une foule mais tu peux aussi
commencé à décrire directement en
décrivant la foule
c'est ce que faisait henderson avec ça
c'est sa mécanique des fluides
donc là tu vas pas cherché à comprendre
où sont les individus et ce qu'ils font
tu vas chercher directement à décrire
les mouvements de la foule de manière ça
s'appelle la différence entre le
microscopique et le macroscopique et
donc tout est allé très sur quoi
exactement quand et à zurich
quand j'étais à zurich jeu c'était le
moment où j'ai étudié où j'ai étudié ces
petits groupes de piétons dont je te
parlais tout à l'heure qui est un truc
qui est fait un truc je veux continuer
sur ce projet parce que c'était c'est
très étonnant le le fait que ce c'est ça
a été reçue de cette manière donc on
étudie des groupes de piétons les gens
qui marchent ensemble tu vas est une
question qu'on s'est posée c'est la
configuration de marche on s'est dit
imagine tu as trois copains qui marchent
ensemble comment ils vont se positionner
les uns par rapport aux autres pendant
leur pendant leurs déplacements et tu
prends toutes les simulations numériques
qui existait donc des modèles qui sont
inspirés de la physique tu fais la
simulation donc en leur ajoutant des
petites forces pour les collés les uns
aux autres des forces d'attraction et tu
vas voir que quand ils se déplacent ils
vont former une forme de v avec la
pointe vers l'avant comme par exemple un
un groupe doit de d'oiseaux sauvages
pendant l'immigration tu vois il soit
enlevée avec la pointe vers l'avant ou
bien comme je sais pas un petit groupe
de cyclistes dans sur le tour de france
ils vont se mettre toujours avec la
pointe vers l'avant ou bien l'avant d'un
véhicule tu vois c'est toujours pointu
quoi parce que c'est la meilleure façon
de d'avancé comme ça en brisant le flux
d'air où le flux opposé quoi donc le
modèle qui vient de la physique il dit
bah les piétons ils vont aussi marchés
pointent vers l'avant parce que c'est la
meilleure façon de faire et on fait nos
observations dans la rue et qu'est ce
qu'on voit que les piétons ils se
mettent en veille pointent vers
l'arrière c'est à dire que tu as en gros
celui qui est au milieu qui recule un
peu et ceux qui sont sur les côtés qui
se met un peu de vent et donc sa forme
un petit v mais avec la pointe vers
l'arrière donc exactement l'opposé de ce
que prédit la théorie quoi ouais et on
s'est dit tiens c'est bizarre machin est
en fait c'est pas si bizarre que ça
c'est juste que si ton si les piétons
sont des particules physique et c'est
d'optimiser la façon dont ils dépassent
bas effectivement ils vont se mettre
point de faire l'avancé rsa va
apparaître tout seul mais c'est pas le
cas en fait les piétons c'est des gens
c'est aussi des êtres humains et ce
qu'ils veulent pendant qu'ils marchent
et papoter c'est discuter les uns avec
les autres
et la meilleure façon pour discuter 7 m
en vais pointe vers l'arrière parce que
c'est la meilleure configuration pour
que chacun puisse voir tous ses copains
en même temps et du coup en fait on a un
conflit ici qui montre que les piétons
passaient des gens et que tous les
modèles qu'on a jusqu'à présent qui font
l'hypothèse que ce sont juste des
particules ils ont un problème parce
qu'il néglige l'aspect humain dans cette
modélisation et donc
un des principaux des principales
contributions que j'ai fait pendant mon
passage à zurich c'était justement
d'aller étudier ces groupes de piétons
et d'une part et puis d'autre part
d'aller développer un nouveau modèle qui
est un modèle construit sur un purement
comportementale donc il fait pas de
d'hypothèses physique qui est construit
sur sur le sur les interactions sociales
entre les gens vers un modèle qui est je
pense plus réaliste parce qu'il fait pas
d'analogie va pas dire les piétons sont
des particules où la foule est un fluide
on va juste dire ben les piétons sont
des piétons et puis on va como modéliser
leur comportement comme ça ça se
marierait pas ça sympa c'est
incompatible avec l'autre
enfin on peut pas considérer que ajouter
les hypothèses pour continuer à traiter
peut-être des groupes d'individus comme
des particules mais est-ce qu'on peut
varier un peu les deux leaders mondial
quand ouais on peut on peut marier les
deux modèles mais d'une façon un peu
différente
c'est juste que à mon avis et puis je
pense que c'est assez reconnus comme ça
maintenant dans la communauté
c'est que là la meilleure façon de faire
quand tu es à faible densité ou à des
densités intermédiaire c'est de
considérer que les gens sont des gens et
puis d'aller décrire leur comportement à
l'aide de petites règles
comportementales quoi vraiment ne pas
faire des analogies de les considérer
comme des gens sauf que quand tu
commences à mettre de plus en plus de
monde
joe augmente la densité d'individus dans
ta foule ben à un moment donné le modèle
il va il va plus trop marcher parce que
ce qui se passe c'est que les les
individus dans la foule ne vont plus
être libres de leurs mouvements ils vont
plus décider de west qui vont se
déplacer ils vont juste subir des
pressions physiques qui sont exercées
par leurs voisins imagine une foule très
dense où tu te fait bousculer dans tous
les sens
ben en fait que tu aies envie d'aller
dans un code d'un côté ou d'un autre ça
change rien parce que t'as pas de
liberté de mouvement dont mouvement à ce
moment là il va être purement et
exclusivement décrit par les pressions
physiques que tu reçois de la part de
tes voisins qui te bouscule et bien à ce
moment là le modèle de particules par
exemple il marche super bien et donc en
fait ce qu'on a c'est on a une
transition qui va se produire entre une
entre un modèle comportemental est un
modèle physique et cette transition elle
va s'opérer à partir du moment où les
gens commencent à se toucher
physiquement donc c'est une densité qui
se trouvent autour de 5 6 personnes par
mètre carré
et est ce qui est super c'est que
vraiment on passe d'une discipline à
l'autre
quoi tu vois on se contente du
d'augmenter le nombre d'individus et
tout de suite tu vas passer du coût de
la licence comportementale de
l'éthologie ada physique à de la
mécanique des fluides uniquement en
augmentant le nombre d'individus et moi
je trouve ça super ce que j'imagine bien
dans une foule mais enfin j'ai joué
souvent que lorsque je suis parce que
j'ai avec deux autres amis on marche en
pointe à l'arrière mais si la foulée et
danse et qu'on a envie de vraiment envie
d'avancer
on arrête de parler et puis il y en a un
qui suis un peu de vent pour pour se
faire un chemin et puis d autres sucres
du coup je vois cette transition de
phase ouais donc là le logo la
configuration de marche point de vers
l'arrière tu peux la voir comme un
triangle
donc si tu as trois individus tulle et
connect a fait ça fait un petit triangle
avec la pointe vers la vers le bas ou
vers l'arrière
eh ben plus il ya de monde devant toi
plus il ya un flux opposé constante plus
ce triangle il va devenir aiguë donc il
va être de plus en plus serrés tu vois
et puis quand il ya plein plein de monde
et bien tu vas te retrouver avec les
trois qui marche à la queue leu leu
l'un derrière l'autre et c'est ce que tu
fais quand tu es un festival avec tes
potes tu veux avancer on se met à la
queue leu leu parce que là ça avance
plus du tout si on se met en triangle
donc il ya cette continuité en fonction
de la densité très vite si on est un
gros plus grands
on tend un peu plus encore vers une
histoire de pointer peut-être que
derrière comme le chemin et creuset
d'une certaine manière les autres et
elles sont un peu plus enlevée ouais et
puis surtout il ya un autre aspect c'est
que si tu as un groupe plus grand tu vas
tu vas avoir tendance est divisée donc
un groupe de dix personnes il tient
jamais il tient jamais en enlever pointe
vers l'arrière en marchant dans la rue
il va y avoir un truc il va y avoir un
truc qui va se produire je vais avoir un
poteau il va y avoir un peu de gens qui
fait que le groupe va se diviser et la
taille qu'on retrouve la plus frais le
plus fréquemment c'est entre trois et
cinq individus par groupe hockey et du
coup et ensuite quand tu es passé à
berlin tête à changer un peu de sujet
alors j'ai j'ai continué nos jeux ouais
donc gg on dit j'ai diversifié mes
recherches
ok donc donc en gros tu commences à
avoir plus de plus de moyens plus de
temps donc là il commence et je commence
à avoir des étudiants aussi par exemple
la travailler sur le même sujet donc tu
as plus de force de frappe en quelque
sorte donc plutôt que de continuer juste
de tout mettre sur le déplacement des
piétons
tu diversifie tu ouvre un nouvel axe de
recherche et moi j'ai ouvert un premier
axe qui est celui de la contagion
sociale
donc c'est l'étude de tous ces
comportements qui se propage d'une
personne à une autre sans vraiment qu'on
s'en rende compte et j'ai ouvert un
troisième axe récemment qui est celui de
l'intelligence collective où tu vas te
demander comment tu peux intérêt à
intervenir sur le système pour rendre la
foule intelligente mais j'ai toujours
aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle j'ai
trois axes de recherche qui sont le
déplacement collectif donc les piétons
que j'étudie depuis le début de ma thèse
la contagion sociale et l'intelligence
collective et j'essaie de répartir un
peu m'efforce donc mais fort c'est à
dire grosso modo mon temps et mes
étudiants sur les trois en fonction de
ce que jugent eux le plus intéressant
sur le moment quoi d'accord et du coup
c'est quoi que tu trouve le plus
intéressant soit en ce moment j'ai
tendance à être pas mal biaisé sur sur
les thèmes de l'intelligence collective
est là on est on est vraiment on n'est
plus du tout dans
on n'est plus du tout dans le
déplacement des foules enfin il ya
quelques liens avec le déplacement des
foules comme je le disais tout à l'heure
avec les autoroutes de piétons qui sont
une forme d'organisation qu'on pourrait
considérer comme intelligente mais on va
on va se poser des questions qui sont
plus de l'ordre du jugement collectif on
va se dire ok si tu as un groupe
d'individus qui doit prendre une
décision
comment il faut structurer les
interactions entre les individus pour
que la décision soit la meilleure
possible
ou bien de l'ordre de la résolution de
problèmes ou tu dis ok t'as un problème
à résoudre l'un des problèmes
d'optimisation un problème mathématique
n'importe quoi ta 100 personnes qui sont
prises au hasard dans la rue et tu dois
organiser ces 100 personnes pour que l
te donne la solution du problème le plus
efficacement possible
donc tu peut par exemple demander aux
100 personnes les unes après les autres
de donner une solution par exemple tu
vas te retrouver avec sans solution il
va falloir les agrégés c'est sans
solution pour rentrer ou pour en avoir
une qui serait la solution collective ça
c'est une façon de faire oui mais tu
peux prendre tes 100 personnes et puis
tu les as soit autour d'une table et tu
dis bah va discuter essais libres là
mais vous allez me trouver une solution
vous avez une heure donc les mecs et
discutent ou les où les gens les femmes
enfin tout le monde discute les uns avec
les autres et puis ils te sortent à une
solution consensuelle en quelque sorte
ou bien tu peux aussi avoir une autre
organisation où tu dis aux gens vous
avez passés les uns après les autres et
puis chacun essaie de 2,2 d'améliorer la
solution qu'a proposé le précédent tu as
a créé une sorte de chaîne tu vois où
chacun passe derrière l'autre et puis
chacun essaie de rajouter un petit
détail de corriger un petit truc qui est
un peu le modèle qui est utilisé sur
wikipédia par exemple tu as une
succession de petites améliorations dans
quelque sorte ça c'est une autre façon
de structurer la foule qui s'appelle la
stib mairie et est en gros la question
c'est ok t'as un problème tu as plein de
gens comment tu vas les structures et
pour que ça marche le mieux
et puis la réponse n'est pas simple en
fonction du problème en fonction des
gens en fonction de plein de choses
eh bien il faut prendre plutôt une
solution ou plutôt une autre
je peux je peux élaboré si tu veux par
exemple si tu as un problème de un
problème très simple un problème
d'estimation ok tu veux savoir quelle
est la hauteur de la tour eiffel tu sais
pas c'est ton problème tu veux savoir
quelle est la hauteur de la tour eiffel
et puis ta 100 personnes qui ont été
prises au hasard là dans la rue tu vois
et puis il arrive et tu dis ok comment
je vais faire maintenant avec mais sans
personne pour trouver la hauteur de la
tour eiffel bâle a clairement la
meilleure façon de faire c'est de les
isoler des 100 personnes qui les isole
donc ils se parlent pas et tu leur
demandes chacun à chacun leur tour de de
te donner la hauteur de la tour eiffel
tu vas te retrouver avec 100 estimations
différentes une certaine qu'ils sont
complètement pourri du huard des gens
qui vont dire 5000 mètres d'autres qui
vont dire 30 m ok tu vas voir une
distribution de d'estimations et en fait
si tu prends la médiane donc une vanne
une sorte de valeur moyenne de toutes
les estimations
tu vas retrouver une valeur qui va être
très proche d'eux 360 380 mètres qui est
la bonne réponse la bonne réponse a est
parlant en fait pour une tâche
d'estimation la médiane d'un grand
nombre d'individus d'un grand nombre de
jugements indépendant est souvent proche
de la bonne réponse
et ça c'est des statistiques sert à
faire un effet statistique tout simple
c'est juste que en gros
vu qu'on a tous une culture commune la
probabilité pour que tu tombe sur un mec
qui surestiment la hauteur de la tour
eiffel d'un certain écart est exactement
la même que celle que tu tombe sur un
mec qui va là sous-estimée du même écart
donc si tu as plein de gens tu vas te
retrouver avec autant de personnes d'un
côté que de l'autre et donc tu prends la
moyenne ou la médiane pour éviter les
les valeurs extrêmes
et tu vas tomber sur une valeur qui est
très proche de la bonne réponse non en
fait pour les tâches d'estimation toute
simple et bien il faut garder
l'indépendance est agrégé des solutions
a posteriori en utilisant la moyenne ou
la médiane il ya plein de façons
d'agréger les dents cette méthode là il
ya plein de façons d'agréger les les
solutions par exemple il ya un problème
d'optimisation très connu qui est le
problème du comment ça s'appelle en
france et du voyageur de commerce je
pense c'est ça ou tu as plein de points
dans un tas plein de points sur une
carte par exemple et puis tu dois
essayer de les connecter en faisant le
chemin le plus court possible me faut
que tu connais que tous les points avec
un chemin le plus court possible comme
un facteur qui veut faire une tournée en
ville et puis il doit utiliser le moins
de décence possible il est en voiture
par exemple pour collecter toutes les
toutes les habitations et donc c'est un
problème d'optimisation qui est super
complexe
tu peux tu peux trouver plein de
solutions différentes et puis il ya des
chercheurs qui travaillent sur le
problème d'intelligence collective qui
disent ok ben moi je vais demander à mes
100 personnes de me donner une solution
aux mêmes problèmes et puis ils ont
trouvé une façon d'agréger c'est sans
lui c'est sans solution donc laissant
graff là en regardant quels sont les
lieux qui sont connectés les plus
souvent les uns aux autres et puis en
gardant grohl ce que décide un peu la
majorité des des 100 personnes ça donne
une solution collective et cette
solution collective elle a des
propriétés qui sont très intéressantes
elle est souvent bonne
et puis elle l est pas comment dire elle
n'est pas dépendante du nombre de noeuds
alors qu'un programme informatique par
exemple il va avoir un problème quand
c'est un très gros graff bas une foule
elle va pas avoir de problème quand
c'est un très gros graf
donc elle le temps de solutions pour une
foule va augmenter linéairement avec le
nombre de noeuds dans ton graf
alors que pour un ordinateur ça augmente
exponentiellement donc il ya des
propriétés intéressantes d'avoir ce
problème qui est résolue par une foule
donc ça c'est la première façon de faire
tu vois c'est quand tu demandes à des
gens indépendamment de leur donner une
solution et puis tu les agrège ensuite
cesserait fond c'est ce qu'ont fait par
exemple en dans une démocratie on va
demander à chaque individu de donner son
avis sur un option une un choix
plusieurs options qui est le choix du
président et les plusieurs options c'est
les candidats sauf que on sait que ça
marche très bien
quand ce sont des avis indépendants donc
si tu prends tout le monde en france et
que tout le monde doit choisir un
président mais que les gens ils n'ont
pas le droit de parler les uns avec les
autres
aucune interaction entre les gens mais
tu vas voir un choix à majorité qui va
être en général bon sauf que ce qu'est
ce qui est étonnant et assez constructif
c'est que ça pourrait être meilleur que
küng à libération les battre ensemble
alors ça ça dépend donc sur cette
question il n'y a pas de consensus
scientifique pour le moment donc tu
retrouves d'aider des études qui vont
comparer sur une tâche donnée
l'agrégation de jugement indépendant
avec le consensus donc les gens qui ce
soit autour d'une table et qu'ils
décideraient ensemble qu'est ce qui est
la bonne solution
et puis des fois ça s'est mieux d'un
côté et puis des fois c'est mieux de
l'autre côté est en fait à l'heure
actuelle on les chercheurs on n'a pas
encore compris vraiment quels sont les
facteurs qui font que ça va être mieux
pour un certain problème d'utiliser une
délibération est mieux dans pour
d'autres d'utiliser des années des avis
indépendants
c'est juste que c'est juste en ce moment
tu regardes la littérature scientifique
tu vas avoir autant de preuves dans un
sens que dans l'autre quoi et comme
c'est toujours il ya plein de facteurs
qui entrent en jeu et bien on a du mal à
discerner quels sont les facteurs qui
sont les plus importants à ce moment là
quelles seraient les facteurs candidats
feraient j'imagine que le problème ou
charge à 6 mais je vous dis non joue
beaucoup est la nature du problème le
fait que qui va t'impliquer et
émotionnel
emotionnellement ou pas et aussi surtout
la lah les propriétés des gens qui sont
en train de discuter
est ce que dans le groupe il ya des
experts est ce que dans le groupe il ya
des gens qui parlent plus que d'autres
est-ce que là le temps de parole est
parfaitement équilibré ce genre de
choses il ya une étude il ya une étude
vraiment génial qui est sorti il ya
quelques années je crois que c'était en
2011 un truc comme ça par des chercheurs
du hem haïti et qui ont étudié
qu'est ce qui dans qu'est ce qui rend un
groupe d'individus qui essaient de
résoudre un problème efficace ou pas
efficaces et donc ils sont allés
regarder plein de critères donc en gros
ils ont ils avaient des participants
c'est une expérience ils ont des
participants et ils font passer à ses
participants plein de tests
individuellement
juste des tests psychométriques donc on
veut juste voir quelle est leur qi
quelle est leur sensibilité émotionnelle
quelle est leur sensibilité sociale
plein de choses quoi donc là tu as des
participants ils sont décrits par tous
ces tests
et puis ensuite on fait des petits
groupes ou d une groupe moyens et on
demande à ce groupe de résoudre des
problèmes donc résoudre un problème t2
d'optimisation de résoudre un problème
de délibération de faire des trucs comme
ça et on regarde quels sont les groupes
qui ont eu les meilleures performances
et parmi ceux qui auraient ensuite on
compare ce qui ont eu les meilleures
performances de ce qui ruine les moins
bonnes performances et on regarde quels
sont les critères individuels qui font
qu'un groupe bam a mieux marché qu'un
autre est en fait le par exemple
étonnamment le le qi des individus du
groupe
le qi des membres du groupe n'a aucun
impact tu peux avoir des groupes avec
des gens qui ont un très fort qi qui
vont avoir des performances pourri et à
des groupes avec des gens qui ont faible
qi qui vont avoir des très bonnes
performances aux portes est le le qi des
individus ne va pas déterminé le qi du
groupe en quelque sorte
par contre ils ont trouvé un autre
critère qui qui est très bien corrélé
avec la performance du groupe salins
c'est c'est une mesure qui s'appelle la
sensibilité sociale
donc c'est un truc que tu peux mesurer
rapidement à individuellement il ya un
test qu'on peut faire pour ça qui va te
juste dire à quel point tu arrives à
identifier les émotions des gens avec
qui tu parles donc le test par exemple
il est super marrant c'est très simple
tu vois tu as une photographie d'un
acteur qui en train d'exprimer une
émotion c'est juste une photo donc la
colère la tristesse la joie et tout ça
et la photographie elle est coupée au
niveau des yeux en fait tu vois juste
les yeux de l'acteur ok tu vois juste
une petite bande avec les yeux et tu
dois dire tu as impulsé m un choix
questions à choix multiples tu dois dire
qu'elle est l'émotion qui est exprimé
par ce regard est en fait à des gens qui
sont super forts pour faire ça tu as des
gens qui ont eu en tout juste puis en a
d'autres qui sont nuls quoi il n'arrive
pas du tout ils ont leur prix se
trompent juste en regardant les yeux et
en fait si tu regardes la sensibilité
sociale se meut cette mesure de moyenne
dans le groupe
eh ben tu vois que les groupes qui ont
des individus à forte sensibilité
sociale ce sont ceux qui ont les
meilleures performances et les groupes
qui ont des individus à faible densité
physique sociale c'est ceux qui ont les
moins bonnes performances donc là tu as
un critère qui est qui est très
fortement corrélé avec la performance et
la sensibilité sociale et juste pour
terminer parce que c'est vraiment cool
juste pour terminer il se trouve qu'il
ya une différence hommes-femmes dans les
mesures de sensibilité sociale il trouve
que les femmes ont en moyenne des
meilleures notes en termes de
sensibilité sociale que les hommes
par conséquent tu te retrouves avec ces
groupes qui sont composées de femmes
majoritairement qui en font en fait les
groupes qui ont les meilleures
performances par rapport au groupe qui
ont pompé considère constitué uniquement
d'hommes par exemple assurances et du
coup est ce que est ce que du coup il
faudrait enseigner les gens entraînés
les gens à regarder des photos de dieu
deux autres personnes et là je sais pas
parce que si tu fais ça tu va les
entraîner à avoir une bonne note aux
tests mais tu vas vraiment transformer
le tous les comportements qui sont qui
sont impliqués par le test de ses
patients j'étais sais pas trop je sais
pas trop où ça va mais en tout cas c'est
c'est une découverte
donc là tu vois ça c'est juste pour
prendre un peu de recul sur la
conversation
donc ça c'est un facteur qui va avoir
une influence sur la performance du
groupe dans mode consensus et
et il y en a plein des comme ça tu vois
et donc avant de pouvoir te dire est ce
que ça marche mieux de mettre son groupe
en discussion faire un consensus ou
d'avoir des agrégations d'avis
indépendants et bien il ya il ya encore
du travail quoi ce cas que des mecs très
bien et puis après tu as encore d'autres
façons de faire un tout va là on parle
du consensus et de l'agrégation il ya
aussi comme je disais tout à l'heure la
plastique bergie donc le fait d'avoir
les gens qui essaient de résoudre un
problème à la chaîne donc en passant les
uns derrière les autres et donc ça c'est
aussi une forme de travail
d'organisation qui marche bien ça aussi
le le je ne sais pas comment comment
comment l'appeler mais une sorte de le
découpage en quelque sorte où tu as un
problème super compliqué mais que tu
peut découper en petits morceaux très
simple et donc en fait tu fais ton
découpage du coupon problème en petits
morceaux et puis tu distribues un petit
morceau à une personne et puis comme ça
tu vas voir la personne qui va le
résoudre super facilement quelques
secondes et tu fais ça tu as en personne
peut-être tu découpes ans en morceaux et
des découpes tu distribues les 100
morceaux à chaque personne et ensuite tu
récupères des morceaux et tuerait
assemble la solution de ton problème
c'est tous les problèmes de recherche
par exemple l'usagé data la nasa par
exemple quand elle quand elle cherche
des des formes de d'astres lâcher un peu
nu dans notre physique du coup quand la
chair des formes des formes
particulières dans des captures du de la
voûte céleste ou des choses comme ça des
photos et ben ils ont des millions de
photos et ils n'arrivent pas entraîner
un ordinateur pour le faire donc en fait
ils vont découper tout tout là toutes
les photos qu'ils ont en plein de petits
morceaux il distribue les petits
morceaux un plein d'individus donc à une
foule
et puis ensuite il récupère les morceaux
et puis ils reconstituent tout tu as un
chercheur qui est un peu à l'origine de
ceux de cette façon de faire qui
s'appelle un informaticien qui s'appelle
et ça choquera qui s'appelle jim jim
gray et c'était un informaticien
de génie et il adorait la voile et un
jour c'était en 2007 je pense il est
parti en voile au large de la californie
et puis il a disparu en mer il n'est
jamais revenu et ses collègues étaient
super triste et où est ce qu'ils ont
fait en fait c'est que ils sont allés
appliquer ces principes pour la
recherche du bateau pour la recherche
pour voir s'il pouvait retrouver jean
grey en étudiant ce principe dans ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est qu'ils ont
récupéré plein de photos satellites delà
de l'océan a souvent droit là ils ont
découpé des photos satellites en plein
de petits morceaux et ils sont allés
faire un appel sur internet en disant
est ce que vous voulez participer vous
avez juste une photo à regarder et vous
nous dites si vous voyez le bateau sur
cette photo est donc ils ont distribué
des dizaines de milliers de photos à des
dizaines de milliers d'individus
et puis chaque personne disait non j'ai
pas vu le bateau non j'ai pas vu le
bateau est donc ça permet de distribuer
travail en quelque sorte entre plein de
petits yeux enquête pour ainsi dire il
ya une inde et des membres de la foule
qui a repéré quelque chose qui
ressemblait à un bateau mais quand ils
ont envoyé les secours à cet endroit là
le la cette chose qui était possiblement
le bateau n'était plus là donc ils
avaient peut-être coulé et ben
malheureusement l'histoire se finit mal
parce qu'ils n'ont jamais retrouvé jim
gray mais c'était juste pour te donner
cette petite histoire de la façon dont
le site dont le système devrait aussi
être appliqué
c'est intéressant est ce que peut-être
que du coup il monte de 2 d'efforts pour
découper les problèmes on prend des très
gros problème c'est intéressant de
chercher du coup à les découper pour
mieux distribuer les tâches sur souci là
beaucoup de gens qui sont prêts à
contribuer ouais c'est le principe
général d'aider science participative où
tu vas faire un lancer un appel sur
internet pour demander aux gens de jeu
c'est pas de te donner
des infos sur la faune et la faune et la
flore qui sont autour d'eux dans leur
jardin ou dans la forêt donc en fait tu
découpes un l'espace en plein de petites
zones qui sont les zones autour des gens
qui veulent participer mais comme ça tu
récupères plein d'informations
géolocalisées
si tu voulais faire une appli pour voir
quelle est la météo et différents
endroits du monde tu pourrais juste
demandé à plein de gens de t'envoyer la
météo à leur endroit actuellement un
pilote immédiatement torre une
cartographie de la météo ou on n'a pas
besoin de faire ça mais c'est juste un
exemple taata ya vraiment plein
d'exemples un voeu
je ferai une vidéo assujettir je me dis
parce qu'il ya vraiment trop de il ya
trop d'exemples y en a pris elle a plein
qui se bousculent dans ma tête je vais
pas tous les dires d'un un super truc
c'est la cartographie de crise donc par
exemple quand à un endroit une
catastrophe naturelle qui se produit ça
peut être je sais pas un
une tornade un tsunami un tremblement de
terre quelque chose comme ça où même
quand si c'est un attentat terroriste ou
des choses comme ça donc à un moment
donné tu as une crise et il faut vite
que les forces de secours que les
secours sache
qu'est ce qui se passe et où sont les
blessés et qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et
un chercheur que j'adore qui s'appelle
duncan watts probablement mon cherche à
préférer de loin qui a utilisé la foule
pour aller faire cette cartographie donc
il a dit ok on va recruter des
participants qui vont aller faire des
des recherches sur sur les réseaux
sociaux par exemple pour aller voir ce
qui se passait ou ça se passe et puis il
ya une carte qui est commune pour tout
le monde et puis chaque individu va
aller à noter cette carte et tout le
monde peut corriger ce qu'a fait l'autre
a model modèle wikipédia si tu veux donc
chacun est libre d'apporter sa
contribution et de d'enlever les
contributions des autres ou de les
corriger ou jeu tout le monde est libre
et au fur et à mesure tu as une carte
comme ça qui va émerger avec plein de
petites annotations et il se trouve que
cette carte elle a à peu près la même
qualité donc le même taux d'erreur que
les cartographies qui sont faites par
les professionnels
sauf que celle qui est faite par la
foule tu peux la faire en quelques
heures alors que les professionnels ils
doivent se rendre sur place et ça va
prendre plusieurs jours
donc tu peux te servir de la foule comme
ça modèle wikipédia pour faire des
cartographies de crise sans même envoyer
les gens sur place un juste en demandant
gens de faire leur propre recherche sur
les réseaux sociaux donc juste de voir
en regardant ce qui se passe autour
d'eux à quel endroit il y aurait un
problème ou pas donc tu as des gens qui
témoignent ici il ya des blessés tu mets
un petit à petit d'un petit point
blessés à l'endroit où ou le tweet si
ces tweets sur twitter et géolocalisés
par exemple voilà donc il ya des
différentes façons de résoudre des
problèmes je vais faire je vais je vous
en parlerai sur sur ma chaîne provisions
je regarde vite fait sur le la
sensibilité émotionnelle
parce que du coup voilà la question qui
se pose c'est à ce que les gens sont
inquiets qui donc ils sont capables de
détecter à l'émotion d'une personne à
partir d'une photo de ses yeux parce
qu'ils sont meilleurs ensuite dans les
débats ap la cause de ça de cette
capacité à détecter ça ou est ce que il
y aurait pas parce que ça serait pas
juste un signe qui font juste beaucoup
plus attention à l'environnement général
de des débats on sait pas exactement
mais il ya des hypothèses et il y en a
une par exemple qui est mon hypothèse
avec un projet que je suis en train de
conduire en ce moment qui est vraiment
que le fait que quand un camp quand à un
groupe d'individus qui interagissent les
uns avec les autres pour résoudre des
problèmes plusieurs fois de suite
il ya une sorte d'apprentissage social
qui se met en place
ou tu vas commencer à identifier les
qualités et les défauts de chaque de
chacun de tes partenaires
tu vas dire ah tiens à lui il est balèze
quand il s'agit de calculer lui il est
fort quand il faut de la culture
générale des choses comme ça et tu vas
apprendre à écouter les bonnes personnes
au bon moment donc en fonction du
problème qui a tu vas dire ah ça c'est
plutôt un problème de calcul donc je
vais être tu va tendre l'oreille quand
c'est le mec qui est fort en calcul qui
parle mais il n'a pas dit qu'il était
fort en calcul c'est pas écrit il n'ya
pas d'étiquette c'est juste que tu l'a
identifié au fur et à mesure des
interactions que tu as eue avec lui dans
le passé est a priori les gens qui ont
cette sensibilité sociale plus
importante ce serait mon hypothèse ils
sont capables de deux structures et
leurs réseaux d'interactions donc il ya
un réseau donc tu imagines ses
connexions qui sont qui connecte les
différents individus du groupe
et puis vont donner plus de poids à la
bonne personne pour le bon moment en
quelque sorte
d'ailleurs dans les groupes qui sont qui
sont avec une sensibilité sociale forte
il ya aussi une caractéristique qui est
que le temps de parole est beaucoup plus
équilibré où tu vas voir tu vas avoir
des individus à part une personne qui
parle plus qu'une autre
d'ailleurs il ya aussi
ah je suis pas sûr je vais le dire quand
même mais je suis pas sûr il faut que je
vérifie c'est peut-être pas certain il
ya aussi des mesures de confiance qui
sont prises donc tu dis à chaque
individu est ce que à quel point tu es
confiant de toute la réponse que tu
donnes et que les niveaux de confiance
ils sont plus bas et plus mesuré plus
modérée dans les groupes à forte
sensibilité sociale alors que dans les
autres îles sont plus extrêmes donc en
gros pour faire une caricature dans le
groupe qui marche pas tu vas avoir des
gens ou les temps de parole sont pas
équilibrées donc tu vas voir un gars qui
parle tout le temps par exemple et un
autre qui est timide qui l'ouvrent pain
et tu vas avoir des niveaux de confiance
qui sont qui sont mal mal calibré donc
tu vas avoir un gars qui dit je suis
absolument certain alors qu'en fait il
n'est pas si performant que ça ou
d'autres qui vont sous-estimer leur
leurs comptes leurs performances en
disant je suis pas alors qu'en fait ils
sont ils sont assez forts
bref donc c'est juste une histoire de
bien de bien équilibrer le flux
d'informations et la pertinence des
informations pendant la discussion
la chaussée en face il va continuer
peut-être je suis passé c'est un sujet
qui me fascine camps savent comment
mieux débattre ensemble et du coup à six
y aider des trouvailles que je connais
pas si je sais juste que c'est juste que
la l'échelle de à l'échelle de
l'individu on sépare donc là vraiment la
découverte a été faite elle est à
l'échelle du groupe
la seule chose pour laquelle on est sûr
c'est qu'il ya une mesure qui s'appelle
sensibilité sociale et qui est corrélé
avec l'efficacité du groupe
tout le reste ce sont des
interprétations qui nécessitent encore
d'être vérifiées ouais et puisque ce qui
est remarquable c'est que le truc c'est
pas ça c'est parce que bien distribué le
temps de parole c'est par soit il ya
quelqu'un qui gère ça mais j'imagine que
c'est pas forcément ce qui se passe il
ya un nom en pâture
il ya un truc un peu émergents c'est
assez remarquable c'est pas c'est pas
seulement de de répartir le temps de
parole
de manière démocratique en quelque sorte
ça aussi c'est aussi de réussir à le
calibre et sur la qualité de la personne
qui parle aussi d identifier un mec qui
est vraiment bon et ben c'est lui donner
un peu plus de poids pour ce problème
c'est en particulier avec lui en donner
peut-être un peu moins au problème
d'après parce qu'il sera moins fort dans
cette compétence là il ya un il ya un
billet connu il ya une super public et
des sorties qui est une sorte de le
biais de la démocratie en quelque sorte
où ils ont fait une expérience je me
rappelle plus des noms des individus des
chercheurs j'aurai une expérience où ils
prennent des groupes et délibérément ils
vont mettre dans le groupe
un mec qui est très fort dans le
problème qu'ont qui est posée mais ils
le disent à personne ils ne disent pas
aux membres du groupe donc en fait à un
groupe qui est formé avec un gars qui
est très fort et puis les autres qui
sont nos moyens quoi et en fait il se
trouve que le la tendance du groupe à
chaque fois quand ils doivent prendre
une décision c'est de faire un vote à
majorité d'aller des lettres
démocratique tu vois et il se trouve que
dans ce cas là la majorité c'est pas ça
qu'il faut faire parce que fait un
expert dans le groupe donc c'est il faut
juste l'écouté et les autres il parle
pas parce que c'est lui qui va te donner
la bonne réponse est en fait un billet
c'est que là les gens ont souvent
tendance à s'appuyer sur la majorité le
plus souvent possible
alors que c'est pas toujours ce qui est
de mieux à faire ouais c'est complexe
il y avait vraiment la question de
comment identifier et d expertise dans
tous les sens du groupe est celui qui a
le plus d'expérience au sein du groupe
n'est pas celui qui exprime la plus
forte confiance parce que la corrélation
entre la confiance exprimée et l'
expertise et elle est inexistante
inexistante
oui à peu près n'arrive pas on n'arrive
pas du tout à calibrer à calibrer saint
sauvy même s'il ya pas mal de
sensibilité sociale tourner groupe les
du coup voilà mais d'une d'une manière
générale dans les études qui sont faites
des fois tu as des corrélations en c1
c'est un thème très récurrent en
psychologie parce que la question c'est
est-ce que tu peux utiliser la confiance
exprimée comme un proxy comme un
indicateur pour la qualité du jugement
est en fête
il ya des études qui trouve non d'autres
un peu d'autres inversement inversement
donc là c'est le contraire ça dépend
aussi comment tu mesures la confiance
donc en général elle est exprimée sur
dix ans une échelle de 1 à 6 et exprime
sa confiance dans ce problème donc les
gens n'ont pas les mêmes références donc
un acquis vont dire 5 quand ils sont
moyens confiant et puis d'autres qui
vont dire d'eux quand ils sont super
confiant enfin bref les la confiance
exprimée c1 c'est un peu problématique
dans ce sens là parce qu'après je
m'aligne ça ça correspond pas mal à la
confiance inter personnelles entre
différents individus pour ce que tu vas
voir la de différents degrés de
confiance exprimée par un même individu
est peut-être que ça sert si l'individu
ou moins s'entraînent ils arrivent à
avoir exprimé un degré de confiance
qu'il ya au moins corrélés avec ce qui
est justifiable donc donc c'est à
l'échelle des individus isolés que tu
mesures le degré de confiance
donc tu prends un gars tout seul quand
je dis un gars pardon je veux dire un
participant et c'est pas nécessairement
un garçon désolé pour eux désolé pour la
le type de langage le temps que tu as un
participant et puis tu demandes de tenez
une réponse à un problème et tu lui
demandes d'exprimer son degré de
confiance et et tu vois après 6 en
fonction des réponses qu'il a données si
à chaque fois qu'ils étaient plus
confiants ils avaient une meilleure
réponse que quand il était moins
confiants
et donc là ya pas de coloration là là là
a priori a pas de corrélation ou en tout
cas n'avait pas fiable quoi c'est à dire
que des fois il y en a des foyers en
apparent comprends pas trop pourquoi
en tout cas c'est pas fiable donc
c'était quelqu'un qui dit je suis sur
sap a beaucoup de valeur par contre le
truc c'est que ce degré de confiance il
est vachement fluctuant par exemple tu
prends ça c'est une expérience que j'ai
fait moins tu prends un groupe
d'individus qui ont une faible confiance
dans un jugement qu'ils expriment et
puis tu l'aimés ensemble et tu les
laisses discuter et il se trouve que
s'ils ont exprimé tous un jugement
similaire
ils vont ressortir de la discussion avec
le même jugement mais un degré de
confiance super élevé
on faisait des tests de d'estimation
genre quelle est la hauteur de la tour
eiffel tu vois tu prends tu prends tous
les gens qui ont 10 500 mètres alors
c'est une réponse complètement fausse
tu prends tous les gens qui ont pris ce
qu'ils ont dit 500 mètres et tu l'aimés
ensemble et tu crées une discussion qui
commence à discuter sur la hauteur de la
tour eiffel et 10 à moi je pense 500
mètres moi aussi moi aussi ouais c'est
super et donc ils sortent de la
discussion et sont 500 mètres et ils
sont absolument certain la c1 impossible
de les déloger et du coup en fait on
degré de confiance ils fluctuent en
fonction de ce que tu entends autour de
toi c'est pour ça que la la le
regroupement des gens par idéologie
c'est quelque chose qui est très
problématique sur les réseaux sociaux
parce que tu te retrouves avec des
individus qui ont un jugement qui disons
faux mais qui sont entourés d'autres
gens qui ont le même jugement faux parce
que ils se sont délibérément connecter
avec des gens qui leur ressemblent
quoiqu'il se ressemble s'assemble
et du coup ils vont être dans une sorte
de bulle où ils vont tous être entouré
de gens qui ont les mêmes avis et dont
ils vont se dire bah forcément regarder
autour de nous tout le monde tout le
monde pense la même chose
donc c'est forcément que le c'est le
gouvernement qui a requis à tort c'est
un complot ce genre de chose d'humain
mais en fait c'est juste parce que tu te
retrouves avec avec un regroupement
d'individus qui ont les mêmes jugements
et ça ça a un effet secondaire qui est
d'augmenter le degré de confiance
donc tu te rends tous les gens qui sont
contre la vaccination est en général sur
les réseaux sociaux ils sont où ils sont
connectés et du coup ils s'échangent
plein d'informations ils sont tous
d'accord et puis ils vont être sûrs
d'eux et vont dire mais pourquoi est ce
que le gouvernement maxime toujours les
gens parce que regarder autour de nous
tout le monde est d'accord parce que a
priori c'est pas irrationnel façon tir
quelqu'un au hasard dans la population
et
il faut que je suis d'accord avec lui
sur fait que la twa fait 500 m ça
augmente au moins un peu ma confiance en
fait que tu aurais fait lever 500 m mais
là le problème des réseaux sociaux c'est
que c'est pas une personne tirée au
hasard dans la population exactement et
dans notre expérience on avait
délibérément mis les gens qui pensaient
pareil ensemble si tu prends des gens au
hasard dans la population tu vas ça va
être ça va être nickel parce que tu vas
vraiment avoir un avis un un effet
sagesse collective où tu vas prendre des
gens qui ont différents différentes
estimations différents jugements et puis
en principe autour de la moyenne de tous
ces jugements tu vas voir la bonne
réponse
donc si tu ta juste en fonction de ce
que disent les autres torah la bonne
réponse aussi essayer d'aider des
problèmes il ya il ya des biais cognitif
qui font que le
les estimations de la personne médiane
dans la population et des vies
significativement une façon peut-être
même un anticipable de la bonne réponse
en général là le la médiane de toutes
les estimations va être proche de la
bonne réponse si en supposant qu'elle
est telle que les jugements sont
indépendants et qui a pas eu
d'interaction
à partir du moment où il ya des
interactions où les gens commencent à
regarder ce que pensent les autres
c'est là que les problèmes commencent et
il ya beaucoup d'études qui montrent que
justement quand tu laisses les gens
discutaient avec leurs amis par exemple
donc s'ils sont structurés y sont
structurées par par groupes
communautaires en quelque sorte donc ça
va créer une pole à une polarisation des
jugements les gens vont être de plus en
plus extrêmes dans l'eure dans leur
jugement qu'il soit bon ou faux et si tu
es si tu si tu communiques aux gens une
un indicateur de ce que pensent les
autres pareils ça va ça va ça va être
déformés cette sagesse collective donc
typiquement par exemple pendant une
élection présidentielle tu mets un
sondage où tu dis à tout le monde ce que
pensent les autres
eh ben ça ça va être complètement te
perturbe et l'effet de la sagesse
collective parce que les gens vont
commencer à réviser leur jugement
indépendant en fonction de ce qu'ils ont
vu dans le sondage ils vont se dire par
exemple
ah ben tiens lui je trouvais qu'il était
nul mais il est super populaire donc je
vais aller le suivre donc ça tu vois que
tu suis la popularité ou bien encore tu
vas avoir des votes qui sont
stratégiques où tu vas dire à lui
j'allais pas voté pour lui mais ça me
fait de la peine qui soit aussi bas donc
je vais aller pour lui ou bien tiens je
vais me mettre contre cette personne
donc je vais voter pour lui et c'est
donc tu vas voir des des jugements qui
sont stratégiques en fonction de ce que
pensent les autres et ça perturbe
complètement le l'effet de la sagesse
collective qui est fait l'hypothèse que
les jugements sont indépendants mais je
pense à d'autres un débit et cognitifs
comme veux pas tenter l'expérience de
cannes man sur le pardon de sioux souloy
sanctions dit un truc a pas grand chose
à voir mais on donne des nombres très
très grands pas d'un truc fait un
million de m je pense très très grand
puis juste après on pose la question
quelle est la taille d'une baleine
une vidéo de sciences et tout un tas
dessus la légende ans avoir surestimé sa
du coup si on prend la médiane des gens
qui ont été estimés qui ont donné leur
réponse
avec ça il y aura du coup un billet
rapport exact c'est exactement c'est
exactement l'effet que je décris donc ça
s'appelle un effet d'ancrage donc si tu
demandes à quelqu'un de d'estimer un
nombre et qu' il est exposé à un autre
nombre juste avant et ben il va avoir
tendance à se rapprocher au nombre
duquel il a été exposé juste avant et
l'effet d'ancrage qui peut la voir
pendant d'estimation donc si tu demandes
à quelqu'un quelle est la hauteur de la
tour eiffel il commence à réfléchir et
avant qu'il ait exprimé son jugement tu
ya quelqu'un d'autre qui dit ah bah moi
je pense qu'elle fait 500 m dames effet
d'ancrage donc celui qui va donner la
réponse il y a le 500 m qui arrive en
tête et il va avoir tendance à s il
allait dire 300 par exemple à eelv a
tendance à augmenter un petit peu pour
se rapprocher des 1 100 m et c'est
justement ce rapprochement ce petit
mouvement qu'il a fait dans son dans son
esprit qui va faire que le que l'effet
de la sagesse collectif va plus très
bien marché donc c'est exactement cet
effet d'ancrage qui est en cause dans
dans l'affluence sociale ce que tu
l'aube allemand en fait la gueule à une
question de me pose j'aimerais bien voir
qui me paraît difficile mais les cc si
on fait un sondage et ce même s'ils ont
ce qu'on sait que c'est pas mal de
choses sur le sondage est que l'on
regarde la médiane ça donne un nombre à
quel point ce qu'on peut faire confiance
à ce nombre
quels sont les vrais qu'ils allaient le
degré de confiance finalement à donner à
l'intelligence collective donc pour pour
cette méthode là donc sans généraliser à
toute l'intelligence collective pour
cette méthode qui est de calculer la
médiane des estimations indépendantes
il ya des problèmes très simple où tu
sait vraiment à quoi va ressembler la
distribution des estimations et tu peux
être assez confiant que la médiane va va
tomber juste il ya un truc pour exporter
pour te d'illustrer à quel point je suis
confiant dans le truc c'est que c'est
une expérience que je fais assez souvent
en public et gjp à flipper je sais que
ça va marcher
donc j'arrive quand je fais des petites
conférences grand public les choses
comme ça j'arrive et puis je prends un
bocal un gros bocal et je le remplis de
pâtes des petites pattes
et je demande à au public en secrètement
d'estimer le nombre de pattes qui lie à
dans le bocal et tout le monde va à
m'écrire un petit nombre sur un papier
et puis ensuite je vais rentrer tous ces
petits nombres dans un petit programme
et je vais calculer la média le
programme calcule la médiane et puis
pendant pendant mon tour pendant ma
présentation je dis tout de suite on va
regarder quelle est la bonne réponse
donc je le redis avec 850 pâte et puis
on va calculer la médiane je le fais en
direct et en général ça tombe entre 700
et 900 la médiane alors que tu as des
gens qui ont dit 5000 et d'autres qui
ont dit 50 donc juste pour te dire à
quel point je suis confiant dans le truc
c'est que j'arrive à le faire en public
sans avoir trop peur parce que c'est
parce que je sais que c'est indépendant
parce que je sais que les jugements sont
indépendants je sais que les problèmes
et facile je sais qu'il ya pas de biais
émotionnel on le l'estimation du nombre
de pattes tu vas y a personne qui a un
intérêt caché à dire plus ou moins donc
là je sais que toutes les conditions
sont réunies pour que ça marche bien et
après comme je le disais bien il ya
plein de facteurs qu'ils rajoutent par
dessus ça qu'ils vont avoir tendance à
faire que ça marche parfois bien parfois
moins bien ok super étude du coût total
cherche tout de suite a aussi quitté ans
est aussi intéressé
à ce qui se passe sur internet non les
réseaux sociaux tu peux parler de cette
recherche d'accords donc là on va
s'élancer dans le l'autre axe de
recherche que j'ai qui est celui de la
contagion sociale la contagion
comportementale donc on a bien fait les
trois axes au début on parlait du
déplacement des piétons là après on a
parlé d intelligence collective
maintenant vous parler un petit peu de
de contagion sociale donc la contagion
sociale c'est vraiment juste le fait que
tu d'étudier les choses qui vont
circuler d'un individu à l'autre
et quand on dit les choses ça concerne
souvent les informations donc que tu va
regarder comment une information
particulière va se propager d'une
personne à une autre
tu vas essayer d'anticiper comment elle
va se propager et jusqu'où elle va aller
et qui elle va atteindre
et ça marche pour les informations n'ont
pas manqué leur entrée un peu plus en
détail mais ça marche aussi pour plein
d'autres formes de comportements la
contagion sociale c'est quelque chose
qui nous entourent partout souvent on
fait des choses sans même s'en rendre
compte par contagion sociale même quand
on se déplace dans la rue souvent quand
tu arrives à la gare tu sors du train il
ya des gens qui se déplacent dans une
certaine direction avant même que tu es
le temps de réfléchir ton cerveau il va
dire d'aller dans cette direction nous
dit avoir tendance à suivre leflux
et puis pendant que tu as une fois que
tu as commencé à suivre le flux après tu
vas chercher les indications mais la
premier le premier geste est de suivre
leflux
ça c'est de la contagion sociale en gros
tu as été contaminés par les piétons qui
marchait dans une certaine direction
peut-être la contagion sociale sur
toutes formes de comportements si bien
que tu peux avoir par exemple des
habitudes alimentaires qui sont
contagieuses ou tu vas avoir tendance à
alimenter ou we hate alimenter de la
même façon que les gens autour de toi et
ça ça explique en particulier une super
découverte qui a été faite du fait que
le le l'obésité est l' indice de masse
corporelle c'est un facteur 1
un trait comportement terrain très
physique qui est contagieux donc il ya
une étude qui a été faite
l'étude très connu d'ailleurs c'est le
fait dans la ville de framingham donc
c'est une étude longitudinale du rhum
qui a duré 70 ans qui continue encore
sur un une cohorte de 5000 personnes
et puis sont allés mesurer le réseau
social donc qui connaît qui par exemple
dans le réseau donc ils connaissent tous
les liens sociaux qui unissent tous les
participants à grande échelle et ils ont
plein de mesures sur les participants
dont par exemple le l'indicé de masse
corporelle et sur 70 ans
ils se rendent compte que quand un
individu dans ce réseau a tendance à
prendre du poids bah tu vas voir que ses
amis dans les années qui suivent
prennent du poids à leur tour et puis
les amis des amis
et puis les amis des amis des amis et en
fait l' indice de masse corporelle c'est
quelque chose qui peut être vu comme
contagieux alors le mécanisme de
contagion on sait pas exactement ce
qu'il est c'est probablement dans
l'imitation des habitudes alimentaires
mais ce qui est sûr en tout cas c'est
que tu peux pouvoir l'obésité comme
comme une maladie c'est une maladie
contagieuse
tu as en ça marche aussi avec le hac le
tabagisme par exemple c'est cette base
de données elle est superbe tu tu as
dans ton réseau social donc là en
général c'est pas les gens qui
commencent à fumer ce sont les gens qui
arrêtent de fumer
tu as une personne un moment donné qui a
fait rempli son formulaire là et
remplissent des formulaires tous les
tous les six mois je pense et qui a mis
fumeurs oui oui et soudainement il mais
fumer en ont donc là il a arrêté de
fumer à un moment donné et tu regardes
son réseau social dans les années qui
suivent
et tu vas voir que le fumeur non donc
l'arrêt du tabagisme va avoir tendance à
se propager à ses amis et puis aux amis
des amis
et puis aux amis des amis des amis ce
qui est intéressant c'est que les amis
des amis des amis connaissent pas du
tout le la première personne qui a
arrêté de fumer
ils sont pas du tout en contact c'est
quelque chose qui s'est propagée de
proche en proche
ça marche aussi avec d'autres critères
qui sont par exemple le bonheur ou ou la
dépression mais les gens qui sont deux
qui sont heureux c'est beau à dire eh
ben ils ont tendance à propager leur
joie dans leur réseau social et à rendre
heureux des gens qui ne connaissent même
pas si tu es si je suis excessivement
heureux je vais rendre heureux
mon collègue de travail qui va rendre
heureux sa femme qui va rendre heureux
son son son petit neveu donc le neveu de
la femme de mon collègue de travail
entre eux mais je pourrais de la même
façon la même façon le rendre obèses tu
vois que tu vois qu'il ya des cons est
vraiment façonné par le réseau social
qui nous entoure j'ai parlé de bonheur
de dépression de tabagisme l'alcoolisme
aussi les les activités sportives sont
aussi contagieuse donc si tu es entouré
de plein de gens qui vont courir tout le
temps et ben tu vas avoir plus de chance
de te mettre à courir à ton tour
et si une personne d'un moment donné se
met à faire du sport et bien elle va a
tendance à entraîner quelques amis et
derrière elle donc donc ça c'est le
thème de la contagion sociale d'une
manière générale donc on voit hélas la
chose qui se propage le plus facilement
qui est sûr tellement même le biais de
toute cette c30 de tous ses effets
comportementaux
c'est l'information et et l'étude de la
propagation des informations c'est un
domaine de recherche qui est très très
très appréciée depuis le début des
années 2000 qui a aussi beaucoup de
valeur marketing et économiques
il ya plein de plein de labos privés qui
s'y mettent les eas c'est génial ça
s'appelle le marketing viral et c'est
l'art de dalé envoyé une information sur
un produit que tu vends et de la fère se
propager le plus loin possible
profondément possible dans un réseau
social
et pour ça il faut comprendre qu'à
l'information se propage quel est le
fait que comme quels sont les facteurs
qui vont faire qu'elle va passer d'une
personne à une autre
et puis qu'elle va aller le plus loin
possible et ça c'est des choses qu'on
étudie sur les réseaux sociaux
avant avant les années 2000 étudier la
propagation des informations c'était
c'était un calvaire
par exemple dans les années soixante dix
il y avait une rumeur qui s'est propagée
dans la ville d'orléans qui s'appelle la
rumeur d'orléans fins et edgar morin qui
l'a nommé de cette façon qu'ils disaient
que des jeunes femmes se faisaient
enlevés dans des cabines d'essayage et
puisqu'elle était emmené au moyen-orient
pour alimenter un réseau de prostitution
enfin un truc complètement quoi il m'en
fous mais souvent les rumeurs elles sont
un petit peu foule folle comme ça et tu
veux voir comment comment l'information
comment la rumeur s'est propagée
comment elle s'est déformée aussi et
donc dans les années 70 a pas de réseaux
sociaux dans notre guerre morin il
envoie son équipe sur place et puis ils
vont faire du micro-trottoir quoi ils
vont demander à tous les gens alors quel
jour tu as reçu d'information qu'est ce
que tu as entendu exactement à qui tu
l'a passé et puis ils essaient de
reconstituer reconstitués comme ça le
taux de propagation de l'information
aujourd'hui elle me laisse tomber c'est
beaucoup plus simple tu vas sur tu fais
sur twitter tu écris un programme le
programme de 30 lignes à peu près du
scan to scan les activités twitter et
que en gros tu as un programme qui va
identifier quand une information
particulière et est mise sur le réseau
pour la première fois et puis qui va
regarder qui va l'a relayé par mille et
les contacts de la de l'initiateur et
puis parmi les contacts des contacts et
les contacter contact des contacts et
ainsi de suite jusqu'au dernier maillon
de la chaîne de provocation est comme ça
tu obtiens quelque chose qu'on appelle
une cascade de propagation qui est un
graff avec des points qui représente
tous les gens qui ont eu l'information
et puis des traits entre ces points qui
représente le passage de l'information
et puis ces graphes là qui vont nous
intéresser on veut savoir si ils sont
grands ou s'ils sont petits
donc tu as beaucoup de graves qui sont
minuscules où tu as juste une personne
n'a initiateurs qui transmet
l'information à une autre et puis ça
s'arrête quoi c'est tout tu as et plein
plein plein de graves qu'ils sont tout
petits comme ça va grand très très
grande majorité des graphies sont
minuscules
et puis tu as des graphes jeudi grave je
vais dire cascades plutôt d'un plein de
cascades qui sont minuscules
et puis tu as des cascades qui sont avec
son gigantesque quoi août à un
initiateur et puis tu vas avoir
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes derrière qui vont la recevoir
et la retransmettre et la recevoir et la
retransmettre etc
donc évidemment là la grande question
c'est comment faire comment prédire
quelle information va créer des cascades
gigantesque et là qu'elle va créer
petites cascades et comment faire citer
un diffuseur pour envoyer dans
l'information le plus grand rendement
possible
ouais ça t'arrive pays tu verses ah ben
je peux dire pas que les gués pas que
les youtube
je pense que je pense que si tu as la
sita la formule magique tu peux devenir
très riche
ce qui est rassurant c'est que a priori
a pas vraiment de formule magique parce
qu'il ya énormément de alors c'est juste
qu'on comprend pas mais en tout cas pour
l'instant on qualifie ça beaucoup de 2t
fait de hasard en fait il faut avoir de
la chance dans notre plein de critères
qui peuvent être pris en jeu qui vont
sensiblement augmenter la probabilité
pour que ça se produise etc mais mais
c'est toujours des effets qui sont
faibles quoi t'as jamais un critère qui
est si les présents alors tu fais une
méga cascades et s'il n'est pas présent
alors ça va pas le faire zapata pas ça
ça n'existe pas tu as toujours tu as
toujours dit tu peux augmenté d'un demi
pourcent rendant sa d'un demi pour cent
en faisant ça mais sauf s'il ya aussi ce
facteur en même temps puis en gros et
puis en gros est ce qui en résulte c'est
que c'est que c'est principalement du
hasard tu a par exemple toujours ce
chercheur que j'aime beaucoup qui
s'appelle john watt qui a fait une étude
sur sur le succès des ddd
produits commerciaux d'un bras culturels
en particulier donc été de la musique
sur les sur les réseaux sociaux
et il a réussi à faire une expérience
donc ce qu'il a fait c'est une
expérience géniale paru dans sa haine
c'est un très grand journal elle a plein
de citations elle est super ou en gros
ce qui la c1
il a il a créé une base de données de
morceaux de musique qui sont inédits qui
n'existe pas donc une centaine dont une
centaine je sais plus dans quarante
morceaux de 48 morceaux exactement des
morceaux de musique inédits qui n'existe
pas et puis il a recruté une foule de
participants sur le web
je crois qu'il y avait je me souviens
plus plusieurs centaines de participants
et puis il leur a dit de venir à écouter
les morceaux et puis de se les partager
et puis 2-2 les laïcs et et des choses
comme ça tu vois et après après quelques
temps de ce processus là quand tous les
gens sont venus écouter laïque et
partager les morceaux tu as un morceau
qui a émergé de parmi les autres comme
un hit parade quoi où tout le monde a
dit celui-là mais il est vraiment super
ce morceau c'est trop cool c'est
vraiment dans le sens et thomas sont
donc à un morceau qui est qui s'est
distingué des autres un morceau de
musique qui a été choisie par la foule
comme étant le meilleur hélas ils ont
fait un truc super c'est que ils ont
remis tous les compteurs à zéro
ils ont remercié les participants et par
ses dents sont partis depuis ils ont
recruté un autre groupe de participants
du même nombre tu vois encore plusieurs
centaines qui avait jamais rien écouter
et leur en donner les mêmes instructions
à nouveau et donc ça recommence donc les
gens ils écoutent ils partagent i like
et tout et puis au bout d'un moment et à
un morceau encore qui a émergé hit
parade et tout le monde dit celui-là il
est super sauf que c'était pas le même
que pendant la première expérience
c'était un nouveau morceau et ils ont
recommencé et puis à nouveau tu as un
morceau qui émerge est pas fait encore
c'est un morceau différent est en fait
la conclusion le mot clé de cette étude
c'est le
un peu plus d'actu bellity donc c'est
l'un prédictabilité je crois que ça
existe en france et un prédictabilité
way l'un prédictabilité du de l'effet de
l'effet social sur le succès d'un
produit et qu'en fait tu peux reproduire
l'expérience en gardant toutes les
conditions exactement pareil et ben à
chaque fois tu vas avoir un seul la
seule constante c'est qu'il ya
effectivement un hit parade qui va
émerger va pas avoir un truc homogène
mais quelle hit-parade c est bien c est
exclusivement due au hasard et on sait
pas encore quels sont les critères qui
ont fait que dans un cast et ce morceau
là et dans un cas c'est ce morceau là
peut-être que c'est ces duos aux tout
premiers instants de la dynamique
sociale tu vois les premiers morceaux
qui ont été laïque et comment ils ont
été partagés etc
on sait pas trop en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que à l'échelle du résultat eh
ben ça apparaît complètement aléatoire
ces effets de réseau et côté un peu
virale qui croît exponentiellement
voilà c'est ça aussi c'est très très
vite et vous faire voilà c'est ça et il
n'y a rien de rien de systématique c'est
ça qui est la principale leçon c'est que
y'a rien de systématique dans le fait
qu'ils étaient 1
un morceau qui émergent ou un autre
voilà je sais plus trop où j'en suis
mais c'est vrai que la différence entre
les la propagation des les cascades ddt
des voyous c'est des trucs puisque oui
exactement j'ai dévié un petit peu donc
je te parlais des décès de ses cascades
d'informations donc et donc ils vont
déterminer si un produit a du succès ou
non et donc c'est pour ça que j'ai dévié
sur l'autre expérience et il ya un
chercheur en 2018 c'était l'année
dernière et c'est ça c'était l'année
dernière
duhaime a été encore qui s'appelle sinan
arabe et qui s'est posé une question et
s'est dit bastien ont maintenant on sur
les réseaux sociaux on arrive à
collecter plein de cascades de
propagation comme ça on en a eu des je
vais pas dire un chiffre faut je dirais
des centaines de milliers donc tu
arrives en collecter comme ça des
centaines de milliers dans donc en
quelques semaines et il se dit qu'est ce
qu'on va faire d'intéressant eh ben il a
regardé les informations qui se
propageaient et il est allé se référer
sur un site de fact checking là et puis
il est allé qualifié toutes les
informations pour voir si elles étaient
vraies
au fossé en gros il a fait deux groupes
le groupe des informations fausses et le
groupe des informations vraies et il a
regardé dans chaque groupe si les
cascades de propagation était différente
à ce qu'elle se propage différemment les
vraies et les fausses et il a trouvé
qu'elle s'est complètement différente
effectivement donc ça c'était encore une
grande découverte un grand journal de
publication et il a vu qu'ils avaient en
plus plein de différence entre les deux
donc en gros dans le groupe des fausses
informations tu vas avoir des cascades
qui sont plus grandes
déjà donc qui implique plus de monde que
dans les vraies donc ça c'est un peu
triste nommé il ya plus de monde qui va
être touchée qui va avoir tendance à
relayer les fausses informations que les
vrais tu vas avoir des cascades aussi
qu'ils sont plus rapides donc où chaque
ne s'enchaîne avec un autre noeud dans
une durée de temps qui est beaucoup plus
courte que pour les vraies informations
par exemple
ouais et puis tu vas avoir des cascades
qu'ils ont une structure un peu
différente qu'on appelle verticale par
opposition à une structure horizontale
pour les vraies informations alors une
structure verticale c'est quand tu as
une chaîne de propagation en gros tu as
une personne qui passe informations et
une autre à une autre à une autre à une
autre alors qu'une cascade horizontale
c'est quand tu as plutôt un noyau qui
passent l'information à plein de monde
en même temps
t'as pas de chaîne t'as plus un noeud
qui diffuse qui diffusent à plein de
monde qui broadcast en anglais qui
diffusent à plein de monde alors que
pour les fausses informations pas plus
de verticalité donc c'est plus comme
comme une du bouche à oreille en
quelques sortes et et voilà donc et donc
à cette grande découverte que la queue
en fait la cascade va déterminer par
votre papa déterminer non va va être la
structure de la cascade la nature de la
cascade va être corrélés pas être
indicative de la nature de l'information
qui circule donc c'est ça c'est assez
fascinante parce que du coup on petit et
ça pour reconnaître un peu effectué ce
cancer si on est capable de voir qu'une
information descend d'une très longue
cascade
qu'est ce qu'être très verticale ça
devra diminuer notre l'importance qu'on
attache à un information qui nous est
transmise je pense que c'est un exemple
que ça encourage vraiment à remonter à
la source est vraiment à chaque fois
parce que
il en formation proche de la source ont
plus de chances d'être oui alors de
valider deux choses donc effectivement
d'une part le premier truc que tu as dit
c'est s'il est si les cascades sont
différentes
alors on pourrait programmer un petit
talgo qui va regarder la cascade et puis
qui va te dire si elles est plus
vraisemblablement appartient au groupe
défaut d'information ou au groupe des
vraies informations
et effectivement c'est ce que c'est ce
qui est en train d'être fait mais là on
parle de rechange de recherche qui sont
tous deux récentes mais il ya un
chercheur qui a programmé un algorithme
comme ça qu'ils regardent dans les
premiers instants parce que l'intérêt
aussi c'est d'aller plus vite que les
fans shaker parce que si tu va moins
vite qu'un journaliste finalement le
journaliste il a plus de fiabilité parce
que lui il va vraiment regarder la
nature de l'information et là c'est
l'intérêt c'est que ça va très très vite
donc tu peux avoir un algorithme qui
regardent les premiers instants de la
propagation d'une information qui va
dire ouh là celle-là elle est partie
pour pour produire une cascade qui
ressemble à celle des fausses
informations
et plus le temps passe plus tu vas
affine et honda prédictions et pour dire
si c'est plutôt plutôt comme une vraie
eau plutôt comme une fausse est en fait
le temps 0 de l'étude c'est le moment où
le journaliste aura eu le temps de fac
checker l'information de son côté donc
le challenge le défi c'est vraiment
d'aller à avoir un programme qui va plus
vite que le journaliste est donc
effectivement ton programme il peut
aller super vite mais il va pas être
très fiable au début et puis je regarde
plus le temps passe plus programme il
est fiable et tu peux toujours aller
plus vite que le journaliste et obtenir
un taux de fiabilité d'environ 75% tout
toujours en et en étant beaucoup plus
rapide qu'un facteur humain quoi donc
c'est effectivement c'est une façon de
faire qui est qui qui est prometteuse
disons en tout cas que il y aurait une
forme de possibilité d'identifier le
vrai du faux
de manière automatisée tu m'a lancé
aussi sur le fait d'aller voir à la
source et
effectivement donc d'une part
effectivement quand à des informations
qui circulent c'est bien d'aller voir
d'où elle vient pour voir quel est le la
crédibilité du site en question ou ce
genre de choses sur les réseaux sociaux
en général en revanche en particulier
sur twitter parce qu'on a tendance à un
retweet et l'information qui circulait
se déforme pas tu vois c'est toujours
une copie à chaque fois qu'ils aient qui
reproduite par contre dans le dans la
vraie vie quand on fait du bouche à
oreille par exemple l'information qui
circulait se déforme au contraire il
peut se déformer super vite même et là
l'intérêt vraiment c'est d'aller voir
quel était le message original quand tu
reçois une information parce qu'il est
très probable que la transmission de
l'information est déformé le message que
tu reçois et puis qu'en fait il est il
est piégé dans un sens ou dans un autre
on a fait une expérience comme ça on a
on fait on fait régulièrement des
expériences de deux chaînes de
participants dont on fait grosso modo on
fait le jeu du téléphone en laboratoire
où tu prends plein de participants tu
les connais que les uns derrière les
autres et chaque participant doit donner
au suivant un message est donc toi tu va
initier la chaîne premiers participants
tu vas lui donner un message qui va ce
circulez tu vois comme dans le jeu du
téléphone
et là tu peux mesurer la déformation du
message donc je peux te dire déjà que ad
adela dès le troisième intermédiaire
donc tu as le premier qui donne au
second le second qui donne au troisième
ok donc le troisième déjà il reçoit un
message qui est très fortement déformée
par rapport au message original donc
donc il faut pas aller très loin tu vas
nous dans nos expériences ont créé des
chaînes de 10 participants
c'était pas la peine d'aller à 10 parce
que déjà on a on a tous les faits qui va
se produire entre les trois autres le 3e
et 5e déjà tous les fai va être déjà là
et est en gros ce sont ceux dont on
on se rend compte c'est que le message
qui circule va donc se diminue diminué
en détail petit à petit donc ils
diminuent très vite et il va se déformer
mais il va pas se déforme et de manière
complètement aléatoire
c'est pas juste des erreurs de
transmission random comme ça pourrait
dans un signal électrique par exemple
c'est au contraire une déformation qui
est orienté qui est orienté dans la
direction de ce que pense la personne
qui le véhicule non par exemple si si et
c'est à mais c'est pas nécessairement
une mauvaise intention des individus
c'est un biais cognitifs donc table tu
peux avoir de très bonnes de très bonnes
intentions malgré tout tu vas avoir
tendance
inconsciemment à déformer les messages
pour mettre en avant un petit peu plus
ce qui t'arrange est un petit peu moins
ce qui t'arrange pas tu vois un site à
quelqu'un qui en envoie un message en
critiquant mais mes recherches et ma
chaîne youtube par exemple il va dire
quel est le pour et le contre
qu'est ce qu'ils voient qu'est ce qu'il
va dire qu'est ce qui est bien et ce qui
n'est pas bien par exemple fait et comme
moi je vais répéter à ma copine et ben
je vais avoir tendance à mettre un petit
peu plus en avant ce qu'il a dit qu'ils
étaient bien et puis mon cerveau malgré
moi mais je suis un gars très sympa mais
malgré moi mon cerveau il a tendance à
oublier les défauts les inconvénients
et si ma copine a les mêmes billets que
moi et qu'elle en parle ensuite à une
collègue par exemple eh ben elle va
encore une fois renforcer encore plus
les points positifs et puis les points
négatifs ils vont être encore plus
oublier quoi
et puis petit à petit si tout le monde a
les mêmes pied petit à petit en bout de
chaîne tu vas te retrouver avec un
message qui est univoque qui dit l'être
les recherches de mehdi c'est super et
tout moi j'aurai une aubaine car à aucun
débat à voir et c est donc en fait le
c'est un problème sérieux dans
l'expérience qu'on a fait on a utilisé
un message qui était pas neutre qui
était un problème de santé publique sur
l'utilisation d'un produit chimique dans
la vie quotidienne qui s'appelle de
tricks lausanne et on a fait des groupes
qui étaient biaisés on a fait des
groupes qui sont anti
qu'ils sont militants anti utilisation
de produits chimiques anti industrie
pharmaceutique et ou et puis d'autres
qui sont pas qu'ils ont pas militant
mais qui sont juste neutre et on se rend
compte que dans le groupe des militants
anti produits chimiques le message qui
était neutre au début être complètement
déformée pour pour arriver à quelque
chose qui dit le trick lausanne c'est
cancérigène ne touchait pas c'est un
scandale et ou alors que dans l'autre on
va avoir tendance soit à voir une
sous-estimation du risque parce que
juste le message à neutre donc on
connaît pas le risque d'y avoir une
sous-estimation en disant moi c'est bon
c'est pas si grave que ça il y en a pas
beaucoup
continuer à vivre tranquillement donc
donc c'est très problématique la façon
dont les information circule de bouche à
oreille et en particulier sur les
réseaux sociaux
c'est quelque chose de problématique
parce qu'elle savoir avoir tendance à
engendrer du de l'extrémisme et de la
polarisation
ça fait beaucoup de bien et puis c'est
pas juste
forcément des questions de vrais ou faux
classés jusqu'aux terres retenu le truc
qui t'arrange ce qui est intéressant tu
vois c'est que un individu seul ne va
pas déformer le message de manière super
sensible quoi tu vois on est quand même
on est on est intelligent on est des
adultes et tout mais quand je vais
parler de ce critique qui parle de mes
recherches par exemple jeu malgré moi et
je vais juste un tout petit peu renforcé
le plus c'est un petit peu sous-estimé
négliger le moins tu vois un tout petit
peu je vais pas le faire de manière
ostensible et si la personne d'après as
le même biais eh ben ça va être encore
un petit peu et encore un petit peu et
en fait ça va s'accumuler et puis à
l'échelle de la foule donc c'est
vraiment de manière collective
tu vas te retrouver avec un message qui
est complètement univoque alors que
chaque individu n'a rien fait de mal
c'est juste un petit mensonge pas grande
chose quoi et puis en plus c'est
involontaire puisque tu es cédé 3 ou 5
entre 3 et 5 déjà c'est pourquoi donc je
pense qu'on pourrait parler bien pu
longuement mais on approche un peu de la
fin que c'était un peu de temps donc tu
t'es lancé un peu dans la vulgarisation
enfin quand même carrément avec ses se
livrer
la chaîne youtube je veux parler un peu
de son expérience et ouais c'était
positif
est-ce que tu as aimé ouais c'est de mon
expérience en termes de l'entente que
vulgarisateur tu veux dire ouais d'un
au début je me rendais pas compte que
c'était important
donc pendant très longtemps doctorat
post doc et même un petit peu au début
de postes de chercheurs ça m'intéressait
moyennement et puis un jour parlera par
hasard j'ai été un grand repas de
famille en général je parle pas trop de
numéros cherche ou de mon travail avec
plein de monde et où deux repas de
famille et j'ai commencé à parler de mes
recherches et j'ai été très surpris de
constater que tout le monde
arrêter de parler et puis que les gens
ont commencé à m'écouter alors que je
crois qu'ils étaient intéressés de ce
genre de choses et les gens ont commencé
à poser plein de questions est posée
même des questions sur le métier de
chercheur tu vois pas juste sur le mes
résultats scientifiques mais aussi sur
le métier de chercheur et puis je
commençais à leur expliquer et en fait
il ya je me suis rendu compte que d'une
part ça intéresse les gens
ouais et d'autre part que en fait il y a
plein de trucs que les gens ne savent
pas sur le métier de chercheur et et
j'ai compris que ça pouvait être utile
tu vois pour collectivement pour pour la
société pour tout le monde d'en parler
de dire papa juste de mes recherches
parce que parler de mes recherches ça a
un côté un petit peu un petit peu et
égocentré tu vois où je parle de ce que
je fais mais aussi parler du métier de
chercheur d'une manière générale dans le
livre il ya toute cette partie en cette
perspective en filigrane ou où je parle
pas juste des résultats mais aussi parlé
de comment on travaille comment on y
arrive
des expériences qui échoue par exemple
des problèmes de budget genre de choses
et est donc j'ai décidé d'abord de faire
un blog pour parler mais je n'étais pas
très doué en réseaux sociaux tout ça
donc le blog
il devait y avoir dix visiteurs par mois
donc j'étais satisfait je des comptes
entre personnes qui les lisent par mois
c'est bien c'est quoi ces dix quoi c'est
super c'est
par moi avec tout et et après je me suis
dit que j'allais écrire un livre en
réalité j'ai une collègue qui est aussi
une amie qui s'appelle audrey dussutour
qui est une biologiste à toulouse
l'université paul sabatier travail sur
les colonies de fourmis et sur d'autres
organismes bizarre et elle écrit un
livre en 2017 et c'est elle qui m'a
donné envie et je me suis dis rien c'est
super ça c'est une bonne idée pour
communiquer donc je vais écrire un livre
moi aussi donc là j'ai su partie sur sur
l'écriture c'était un super moment j'ai
beaucoup aimé le moment où j'ai écrit ce
livre
et il est sorti donc là ya pas longtemps
il ya quelques mois fin janvier et j'ai
continué sur le blog parce que là
j'étais parti dans toi j'étais en mode
écriture et puis j'ai découvert youtube
quoi connaissait avant je savais pas
pour moi ou youtube c'est un endroit où
tu mets des vidéos amateur a prise avec
ton avec ton de téléphones cellulaires
dans en classe quand tu fais une blague
et où tu rentres comme ça je pensais que
c'était que c'était juste un ensemble de
trucs pourris youtube je n'imaginais pas
qu'il pouvait y avoir de la qualité est
en fait il ya énormément de qualité sur
youtube il ya des vidéastes qui ceux qui
se mettent sur youtube délibérément tu
vois c'est pas juste un lycéen avec son
téléphone portable en classe il ya des
vidéastes qui font des trucs
professionnelle et qui se mettent sur
youtube et donc ça je vais commencer à
le comprendre et puis là j'ai découvert
alors je vais dire que j'ai découvert en
premier
j'ai découvert j'ai découvert y penser
en premier
et juste derrière six ans étonnante et
après dirty baloji et a hélas j'ai
ouvert la porte et zut et après j'ai
découvert tout le monde et là j'ai
compris que
et j'ai compris qu'en fait c'était ça
peut être un outil formidable pour
communiquer et ça marche vachement mieux
évidemment tu regarde moi j'étais
content avec dix visiteurs par mois sur
mon blog et tu vois 850 cas vu sur une
vidéo tels que c'est pas du tout les
mêmes échelles quoi c'est pas les mêmes
niveaux degrés de magnitude
donc donc je vais essayer aussi
peut-être que c'est une bonne façon de
communiquer c'est ce serait ce serait la
vidéo quoi parce que ça marche mieux et
effectivement ça marche beaucoup mieux
chez taschen youtube pas ici il fait pas
mal de des interventions à la radio et à
des conférences
ouais donc quand tu quand tu publie un
livre tu dois savoir si ce que c'est tu
as des sollicitations dans les médias
pour venir à faire un petit peu de promo
dont ta maison d'édition elle te mettes
oblige presque à y aller parce que elle
aussi elle a un intérêt à ce que tu
ailles dans les médias et donc est donc
rapidement
je pense que dès les premières
interventions que j'ai fait c'était
genre 1 le direct à la tête au carré à
france inter là c'était fin janvier donc
j'avais jamais fait de vraiment de
médiatisation et tout est d'arriver à
france inter il ya plein de monde et
puis tu as le chrono était disons
commence dans 5 à 3 et ton coeur ok mais
comment ça va voici ce que tu regardes
tes mains tu vois que elle tremble dans
tous les sens on essaie de les cacher
les cacher sous la table pour pas que le
journaliste voit que tu trembles et donc
est donc là j'ai fait flipper donc
l'habitude comment cette idée it et
n'arrive pas à se sortir de la tête que
tu as un million et demi de gens qui
sont en train d'écouter ce que tu dis et
ça ça te rend complètement fou donc tu
flippes donc la première fois j'étais
vraiment flippé mais avec l'expérience
tu commences à oublier le micro et
oublie qu'il y avait pas là bas j'ai dit
un million et demi parce que c'était la
tête au carré mais qu'il ya un certain
nombre de personnes qui écoutent et tu
commences à parler vraiment à ton
interlocuteur à temps aux journalistes
comme si c'était un personne quelqu'un
autour d'une table public est les autres
et il a du coup ça marche beaucoup
donc en trois mois j'ai beaucoup
progressé dans médiatisation et c'est un
exercice que tu aimes bien au début je
détestais donc c'était évidemment
stressé comme pas possible donc tu
cherche à éviter le stress donc au début
j'en voulais pas du tout et puis au bout
d'un moment quand tu commences à être
plus à l'aise tu te noies et ses 7 vient
ça devient plaisant c'est bien sympa la
vulgarisation en région en général
alors là oui la vulgarisation des en
général j'aime beaucoup ça il ya un
problème cependant de 2 c'est qu'il ya
24 heures dans une journée quoi ça
c'était vraiment c'est vraiment
problématique il pourrait y en avoir
plus ça m'arrangerait mais du coup du
coup j'ai mes recherches dans la journée
puis des recherches c'est un truc qui
est assez obsédant des fois qui suis un
peu à la maison le soir et et puis et
puis le soir je deviens vulgarisateur
parce que yann pour faire des vidéos ça
prend beaucoup plus de temps que pour
écrire un article de blog et du cou et
du coup le rythme est assez assez assez
assez acharné et il a un petit peu
difficile à suivre alors de plus en plus
j'essaye de faire de la vulgarisation
optimisé pour mon emploi du temps donc
c'est à dire de faire des vidéos qui
découle de ce que je suis en train de
faire en ce moment dans mes recherches
de façon à ce que vous mâcher un petit
peu le travail par avance donc si tu
veux par exemple en ce moment je suis en
train d'écrire à un article de revue sur
l'intelligence collective
l'article de revue ça c'est pour mes
recherches un article de revue s'est tu
passe en revue les différentes études
qui ont été faites et essaie de prendre
un petit peu de recul et de tracer les
grandes lignes pour les recherches
futures us sont en train d'écrire un
article de revue et bien à côté en même
temps que je fais mon article de revue
qui fait même partie fait partie de mon
de mes recherches de mon métier je je je
prends des notes pour des possibles
vidéo que je ferais sur youtube et donc
il est très probable en fait j'en suis
presque sûr que je vais sortir une série
de vidéos sur le thème de l'intelligence
collective qui sont en fait des vidéos
dont le travail est en partie été fait
pendant sept heures que l'écriture de
cet article de revue
donc je fais des choses qui sont sont un
peu cohérente et ça me permet de gagner
beaucoup de temps comme ça il ya un
autre projet que j'ai à plus long terme
ou là je vais vraiment réussir et
idéalement j'arriverai vraiment à faire
converger à fusionner lartigue idée de
vulgarisateur et l'activité de
chercheurs c'est que mine de rien j'ai
j'ai cantal et des abonnés sur youtube
par exemple c'est une foule d'abonnés
des gammes des gens quoi et dont tu peux
tu peux utiliser cette foule d'abonnés
pour faire quelque chose et je suis en
train de construire en ce moment un
projet de science participative où je
vais utiliser le
je le fais comment dire où je vais
inviter les abonnés à participer à un
projet particulier puis on va conduire
tout le projet du début à la fin
ensemble sur youtube tu vois avec les
abonnés et du coup moi je fais d'une
pierre deux coups parce que ça me permet
de continuer sur mes sûr mais sur mes
recherches
c'est un vrai projet de recherche tu
vois que je vais je vais contrôler quoi
on va pas faire n'importe quoi et en
parallèle tu implique de public et puis
les gens ils sont avec toi derrière toi
et puis ça fait des vidéos ça fait de la
vulgarisation parce que tu m'expliques
comment ça se passe après on peut
envoyer l'article à un journal et puis
l'article il revient et on explique
comment se passe le processus de
révision par exemple est peut-être la
tiba est rejeté et où on t'explique tout
au fur et à mesure du projet de a à z
est donc là je en train de construire un
projet comme ça ce devrait être pour eux
pas pour la fin de l'année en principe
ça devrait être sympa oui mais il faut
qu' il faut que soient préparées en fait
on pas je vais pas juste et improviser
un truc et divers et cocan cantelli
collègues vois ton travail de
vulgarisation très bien c'est très
valorisé là où je suis mais il faut que
tu saches que je suis dans un institut à
un peu particulier l'institut max planck
c'est un institut qui est prestigieux en
allemagne qui est riche il ya beaucoup
de moyens et qui a plus vraiment besoin
de faire des pieds et des mains pour
avoir des belles publications parce que
c'est tellement prestigieux qu'ils ont
de toute façon dès les meilleurs
chercheurs ils ont des belles publier
tout si tu max planck qui travaille
maintenant beaucoup sur leur image tu
vois il essaie de donner une image de la
haute d'une recherche par exemple où il
ya autant d'hommes que de femmes
une recherche où il ya des contraintes
éthiques sur les participants qui sont
très strictes une recherche
tu vois de ce genre de chose une de
recherche qui parle qui parle au public
aussi est donc et donc moi je suis dans
un cadre où les mets mes supérieurs il
m'encourage à écrire un livre il
m'encourage à parler etc
et puis ils sont pas bêtes ils savent
que ça va avoir des répercussions
positives sur mes recherches aussi
l'impression que j'en ai en france et
que c'est pas encore le cas c'est que
c'est un point de vue assez moderne
assez récent et en france il ya encore
un petit peu de retard à ce niveau là et
par exemple le fait d'avoir écrit un
livre ou d'être d'avoir une chaîne de
vulgarisation sur youtube c'est pas
quelque chose que je vais réussir à un
mètre sûrement à valoriser sur mon cv
pendant un entretien d'embauché
peut-être que ça le sera dans quelques
années peut-être qu'elle est déjà un
petit peu mais en tout cas quand j'ai
quitté la france il ya une demi douzaine
d'années s'était pas quelque chose qui
était qu'on pouvait valoriser je pense
même que ça pouvait avoir un effet un
peu négatif dans le sens dans le sens
ouais il faut voir ces recherches alors
ils se tournent vers vers un truc plus
facile la vulgarisation par exemple tu
vois un truc à un cliché erronée de ce
genre là
et je pense que la modernité donc c'est
ce qui nous attend même en france je
pense que dans le futur là il va y avoir
beaucoup de beaucoup d'interactions
beaucoup plus d'interactions entre les
chercheurs et les deux publics et qu' il
va y avoir des moyens aussi donné aux
chercheurs pour qu'ils puissent prendre
le temps de faire page pas dans pas dans
la nuit quoi parce que moi je travaille
de la nuit pour ça la même façon
qu'aujourd'hui là où je suis institut
max planck
c'est quelque chose qui est valorisé
donc on approche de la fin
est ce que tu pourrais finir à ce que tu
vois quel est le message clé que tu
aimerais que les auditeurs retiennent de
ceux de cette interview le que que les
que là que la recherche sur le
comportement de foule existe ok 98%
jeudi un chiffre au hasard des des gens
disent même pas que ça existe que ça
c'est une idée d'une part que ça existe
d'autre part que c'est vraiment cool
parce que c'est quelque chose qui
concerne notre quotidien sur les réseaux
sociaux dans la rue etc et que c'est
marrant parce qu'on fait des études avec
des gens et que s'ils veulent en savoir
plus et ben je peux diriger une chaîne
youtube où j'en parle donc ça c'est le
message que je veux transmettre
et puis un livre fuir les vents violents
ce que j'aimerais finir avec deux
recommandations de vidéos podcasts
l'ivho personnes à suivre ah ouais tu me
prend au dépourvu là donc je je
maj maintenant il faut que je sois
originale parce que si je te dis les
grands noms machin se bat mais cependant
il n'ya pas longtemps même si c'est pas
original parce que il ya déjà plein de
gens qui sont dessus mais mais mais tu
as le talent un truc qui est qui a
démarré ya pas longtemps qui s'appelle
le vortex qui est une coloc de
vulgarisateur scientifique
donc tu as quatre vulgarisateur qui
soi-disant vivant colloque je sais pas
dans quelle mesure ils sont vraiment
colloque et puis ils font des vidéos
régulièrement sur les différents thèmes
et donc tu as vraiment une très forte un
outil interdisciplinarité parce que
tanner des vulgarisateurs qui sont pros
dans des disciplines différentes qui
vont interagir les uns avec les autres
et qui vont créer des vidéos et oui cela
ils sont assez réguliers dans la sortie
de vidéos c'est toutes les semaines mois
des cas une vidéo du vortex qui sort je
ne peux plus je vais regarder
directement
là je le mets directement
recommandations sans hésiter
[Musique]
e
sinon un livre c'est plus facile sur
deux niveaux un livre je écoute
il n'y a pas beaucoup de livres
scientifiques que j'ai relu plusieurs
fois mais il y en a un
et d'ailleurs il apparaît même dans ma
dernière vidéo en clin d'oeil là il
apparaît super rapidement à un moment il
est posé sur la table j'ai fait exprès
de le mettre la règle qui s'appelle qui
s'appelle le gène égoïste et c'est une
forme de de révolution dans la façon
dont on voit l'évolution génétique qui
date de je pense que ces années 90 et
début 90 ce qui est vraiment
exceptionnel était à chaque fois que
j'aurai un jour et je me fascine c'est
un peu technique par contre c'est pas
trop vulgariser mais à chaque fois ça me
fascine ok super merci beaucoup
mehdi lacen a invité un vrai plaisir
j'espère que vous auditeurs réveiller
mais aussi penser à la haye et commentée
comme d'habitude et je vous dis à la
prochaine fois probablement tous au
revoir